I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. It is season four. Season four. Holy guacamole. It's Fun Run. It's Fun Run part one. That's right. Because Fun Run was an hour long episode. So once again, we're going to break it down into two parts. Today is Fun Run part one. Written by Greg Daniels. Directed by Greg Daniels. So much happens in Fun Run. It needs to be two episodes. It really does. Oh, first
我是珍娜·菲舍。我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》。而且我们是好朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了终极版《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有亲历者才能告诉你独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士。第四季来啦。第四季。我的天啊。是趣味长跑。是趣味长跑（上）。没错。因为趣味长跑是一集长达一小时的节目。所以我们再次把它拆成两部分。今天是趣味长跑（上）。由格雷格·丹尼尔斯编剧。由格雷格·丹尼尔斯执导。趣味长跑里发生了太多事。必须得拍成两集。确实如此。哦，首先
for sure. For sure. Here is a summary of just part one. Yeah, let's hear it. Yeah, let's hear it. Okay. Michael accidentally hits Meredith with his car and breaks her pelvis. There's so much there already. Already. He gets the whole gang to visit her in the hospital and later discovers she may also have rabies. Angela asked Dwight to give medicine to her cat Sprinkles while she visits Meredith in the hospital. But when Dwight returns, he announces that Sprinkles is dead and he put Sprinkles in the freezer. In the freezer. Also, your television was on. Yeah, my television was on and Sprinkles is in the freezer. Meanwhile, everyone wants to know if Jim and Pam are dating. They insist they're not. They say
那是必须的。绝对的。以下仅仅是（上集）的剧情梗概。太好了，我们听听吧。好的，我们听听。好啦。迈克尔开车不小心撞到了梅瑞迪斯，撞断了她的骨盆。这里面已经有很多料了。已经够多了。他带着大家去医院看望她，后来发现她可能还得了狂犬病。安吉拉请德怀特在她去医院看望梅瑞迪斯期间给她的猫“撒花”喂药。但德怀特回来后，宣布“撒花”死了，而且他把“撒花”放进冰箱里了。放进冰箱里。还有，你的电视机开着呢。对，我的电视机开着，而“撒花”在冰箱里。与此同时，所有人都想知道吉姆和帕姆是不是在约会。他们坚称没有。他们说
they're just friends. But Kevin is not convinced. Kevin really has a being as bonnet about it. Yeah. Why does Kevin care so much? I don't know. He's obsessed. Because this episode begins so dramatically, we felt like we needed to speak with the woman at the center of this episode. Absolutely. We need to talk to Kate Flannery about getting hit by that car. Yes. So guys, Kate chatted with us. Sam, will you play the interview? Kate Flannery is here today, you guys, with her tiny teacup. Hi, Kate. How are you? How you guys doing? It's so nice to see you. Wait, we have to get a picture of you with that teacup. Cody, will you take a picture? It's not tiny. It's a regular size teacup. What's tiny about that?
他们只是朋友。但凯文并不相信。凯文对这件事简直耿耿于怀。对啊。为什么凯文这么在意？我不知道。他太着迷了。因为这一集的开局太戏剧化了，我们觉得有必要采访这集核心事件的当事人。绝对的。我们得跟凯特·弗兰纳里聊聊被车撞的事。没错。所以各位，凯特跟我们聊了聊。萨姆，你能放一下采访录音吗？各位，凯特·弗兰纳里今天带着她的小茶杯来了。嗨，凯特。你好吗？你们最近怎么样？很高兴见到你。等等，我们得拍一张你拿着那个茶杯的照片。科迪，你能拍张照吗？它不小。这是个正常大小的茶杯。这哪里小了？
I don't believe you. It looks tiny. It's regular. Oh my gosh. And you have a little cup and saucer. Here's the thing, guys, Kate Flannery is one of the classiest gals. Her home is spectacular. It is decorated like it's out of architectural digest. It is, every little thing is amazing. And I am not surprised at all that you look so put together and you're having your tea in a proper cup and saucer. Oh my gosh. But now I got my phone off because I was calling. Sorry, guys. Sorry. Take it on air. Take it on air. Who is it? Let's talk to them. I think it was a potential spam, so I hung up on them. I'm sorry. I can't get locked in a time share just for you for the bit. I'm sorry, you guys. I can't. It's
我不信。它看起来很小。这是正常的。噢天哪。你还有一个小茶杯和茶托。事情是这样的，各位，凯特·弗兰纳里是最优雅的女士之一。她的家棒极了。里面的装修就像是从《建筑文摘》上搬下来的。真的，每一个小细节都令人惊叹。你看起来那么精致，而且用精致的茶杯和茶托喝茶，我一点也不觉得意外。噢天哪。不过现在我把手机拿开了，因为我刚才在打电话。对不起大家。抱歉。开着麦呢。开着麦呢。是谁打来的？我们跟他们聊聊吧。我猜可能是诈骗电话，所以我把电话挂了。不好意思。我可不能为了你录节目就被套牢在分时度假房里。对不起大家。我不能这样。
so good to see you. You don't understand. We spent every day together for nine years. I know. Oh my God. I know. It was so much like a real office job in that respect. Just like hours at our desks. And the fluorescent light. Yes. I mean, that has a real effect on you. And the snacks? Come on. That was the best spread. Oh God, we had the best, best food ever. It's all my dad ever talked about. All the years that he visited and I would pepper him with questions about, so Steve Carell ate lunch with us today, wasn't that great? And he was like, did you see the steak they had? It was always about the food. Bill Kinsey. Oh, Kate. It's so good to see you. And Jenna, you guys. You guys. Kate,
很高兴见到你。你们不明白。我们九年来每天都在一起。我知道。哦，天哪。我知道。从这方面来说，这真的很像一份真正的办公室工作。就像在办公桌前坐了无数个小时。还有荧光灯。对。我的意思是，那对你真的有影响。还有零食？拜访啦。那是最好的零食。天哪，我们吃过最棒、最丰盛的食物。这也是我爸爸每次来都会念叨的。他来探班的那些年里，我总是向他抛出各种问题，比如，今天史蒂夫·卡瑞尔和我们一起吃午饭了，不是很棒吗？而他却说，你看到他们准备的牛排了吗？永远都是关于吃的。比尔·金斯利。哦，凯特。很高兴见到你。还有珍娜，你们。你们。凯特，
we always like to start by asking people how they came to be on the office. I actually auditioned for the pilot for the part of Jan. Alison Jones said, I think you're really right for this show, but I don't know if this is your part. So clearly they went a different way with the Lord Harden. And lo and behold, you guys shot the pilot. I remember that summer, I was doing a sketch show once a week that was timed. It was a two-minute sketch show. So literally at two minutes, the lights would go out. It was this live show in Hollywood at this theater on Melrose with one of the Scholar Brothers, Randy, was doing a sketch right before me. And he's like, if you've been watching that British show, The Office,
我们总喜欢先问问大家是怎么加入《办公室》的。我其实为试播集试镜过简这个角色。艾莉森·琼斯说，我觉得你真的很适合这个节目，但我不知道这算不算你的角色。所以很明显，他们在罗尔·哈登这个角色上选了别人。结果你们就拍了试镜集。我记得那个夏天，我每周做一次限时小品秀。那是一个两分钟的小品秀。所以到了两分钟，灯光就会熄灭。那是好莱坞梅尔罗斯大街上一家剧院的现场秀，斯柯拉兄弟之一的兰迪就在我之前演了一个小品。他说，如果你看过那部英国剧《办公室》，
I'm so obsessed with it. He was like the first person to really tell me about it. I was like, yeah, I've seen it a little bit. He goes, you got to watch the whole thing. So I kind of got obsessed. And then come September, late August, early September, I had an audition. I couldn't make the first one because I was in Chicago with my aunt. And then I just came, I figured the part was going to get taken. And they had another session a few days later, and I went in and I read and I remember Alison Jones said, no makeup. And like usually in LA, you know, that means like, you know, mascara, some foundation. It means something. It never really means no makeup. And they're like literally, she's literally had a box of tissues. She's like, no makeup.
我简直迷恋死它了。他是第一个真正跟我提起这部剧的人。我说，好吧，我看过一点。他说，你得把整部剧都看完。所以我有点着迷了。然后到了九月，八月下旬、九月初，我有个试镜。我没能去第一次试镜，因为我和我姑妈在芝加哥。然后我去了，我想这个角色肯定已经被选走了。几天后他们又安排了一场试镜，我去了，读了剧本，我记得艾莉森·琼斯说，不要化妆。通常在洛杉矶，你知道的，这意味着，你知道的，睫毛膏，一些粉底。总得化点什么。这从来不真的意味着不化妆。他们就像是，她真的拿了一盒纸巾。她说，不要化妆。
Wipe it off. Get off, right? Anyway, and then I just remember, there were a few actresses that I knew from Chicago that were there. And I felt like they booked everything. I'm like, I'm never going to get this. But I just remember that room was Ken Quapas and Greg and Alison Jones. And I'm sure Paul, I'm sure there were, you know, Mike, I'm sure all the producers were there, the writer producers. It was like the most unique experience I think I'd ever had in an audition. And then I, when I came out, I got home and then Alison told me to go to Gower and do it again, do it one more time and do less, less, less, do less. And then by the time I got home from there, I found out that I got the part. What? You booked it on the drive home.
擦掉。卸掉，对吧？不管怎样，我只记得，现场有几个我认识的芝加哥女演员。我觉得她们拿下了所有角色。我想：我永远也得不到这个角色了。但我只记得那个房间里有肯·夸帕斯、格雷格和艾莉森·琼斯。我敢肯定保罗也在，我敢肯定，迈克尔也在，我敢肯定所有制片人都在，编剧兼制片人。这绝对是我经历过的最独特的试镜体验。然后我走出来，回到家，接着艾莉森叫我去高尔街再试一次，再演一次，再收敛一点，收敛，收敛，再收敛一点。结果等我从那儿回到家，我就得知我得到了这个角色。什么？你在开车回家的路上就拿下角色了？
It's not girl, wait a minute. I didn't have a cell phone, so I didn't know to get home. That's every actor's dream. You didn't have a cell phone, so you didn't know. Those were the days, man. Like, you know what? They couldn't get hold of you. You found out at home. I was playing hard to get on the drive home. Wow. Well, Kate, I was so excited because when you walked on the set that day, Kate and I had been doing an improv show called Bitch Planet. All Chick Improv. All Chick Improv. And we'd been doing that for years. And then all of a sudden, my good friend was going to be sitting like right behind me for years. That was just amazing. Who knew? When four people were in our audience on a Sunday night for our show.
才没有呢，姑娘，等一下。我没有手机，所以我到家前还不知道。那是每个演员的梦想。你没有手机，所以你当时不知道。那真是个好日子，老兄。就像，你知道吗？他们联系不上你。你到家才知道。我开车回家时还故意拿捏呢。哇。好吧，凯特，我太兴奋了，因为当你那天走进片场时，凯特和我一直在做一个叫“母狗星球”的即兴表演秀。全女即兴表演。全女即兴表演。我们已经演了好几年了。然后突然间，我的好朋友要在接下来的几年里坐在我身后了。这真是太棒了。谁能想到呢？当时只有四个人在周日晚上来看我们的演出。
At 10 o'clock. Kate, do you remember what your audition scene was? Yeah, it was from The Alliance. It was the whole reaction to the surprise party and Michael reading the birthday card and insulting Meredith like crazy. Yes, amazing. Yeah, it was so awesome. So awesome. So awkward. So awful. So awful. Happy birthday. Happy birthday. Well, Kate, we've talked a lot on this show about how once we were filming in that bullpen, we were all in the scene. And so we were all each other's background. And that's very unique.
在十点钟。凯特，你还记得你的试镜剧本是什么吗？记得，是《同盟》那一集。就是对惊喜派对的全部反应，还有迈克尔读生日卡片，把梅瑞迪斯骂得狗血淋头。对，太棒了。对，太棒了。太尴尬了。太糟糕了。太糟糕了。生日快乐。生日快乐。好吧，凯特，我们在节目中讨论过很多次，一旦我们在那个开放式办公室里拍戏，我们所有人都在镜头里。所以我们都是彼此的背景板。这非常独特。
It's not like that on a lot of shows, right? Yeah. So we've sort of talked about the things we did in the background. We talked about how Phyllis looked at Gates. Remember, she looked at Gates for her house for years. I remember they told me when I booked the job that I was supposed to bring paperwork because they really wanted us to be looking like we were working. And I loved that suggestion. I thought it was so like it's so method because then no one is suddenly acting like they're working. They're actually working and the camera catches them, which makes so much more sense. So I actually brought my taxes the first season. I was going to say, Kate, I have a memory of you opening your
很多节目都不是这样的，对吧？是的。所以我们聊过我们在背景板里做的事。我们聊过菲莉丝是怎么看着盖茨的。还记得吗，她盯着盖茨家的房子看了好多年。我记得我得到这份工作时，他们告诉我，我应该带些纸质文件，因为他们真的希望我们看起来像是在工作。我非常喜欢这个建议。我觉得这太注重体验派了，因为这样就不会有人突然假装在工作。他们是真的在工作，而镜头捕捉到了这一点，这说得通多了。所以第一季的时候我真的带了我的纳税申报表。我正要说呢，凯特，我记忆中你一直在拆
mail and like I did. I did. I brought a bag of stuff. And I think I also like snuck reading a book, which is kind of like a thing that people do it in an office anyway, sometimes. Well, especially Meredith. Well, I don't know. Does Meredith read a lot? Maybe not. I got into Solitaire, clearly. That was like my main background choice for so much. But that was so much because the back of my head wasn't so much of it that I, I can't my screen was caught all the time on my computer. So I would just rather than like go to some file at the last minute, I would just dump into Solitaire because I knew I could just get right back into it. And I thought it was a funny thing for Meredith to be multitasking all the time with a game. So stupid. Well, you became
信，就像我做的那样。没错。我带了一袋子东西。而且我想我还偷偷看书来着，这本来就是人们在办公室里有时会做的事。特别是梅瑞迪斯。不过我不知道。梅瑞迪斯读很多书吗？也许没有。显然我迷上了纸牌游戏。那几乎是我大部分时间的主要背景板选择。但很大程度上是因为我的后脑勺经常出镜，我的电脑屏幕也经常被拍到。所以比起临时去找什么文件，我宁愿直接玩纸牌，因为我知道我可以马上切回游戏。我觉得对梅瑞迪斯来说，一边工作一边玩游戏是个挺搞笑的设定。太蠢了。好吧，你玩得
really, really good at it. I actually creed and I would have many, many a competition and I whooped his ass. I am still sort of hung up on the fact that they told you to come to set and bring paperwork. Do they tell you that? No, you know, I don't remember that specifically, but I did bring some. I used to write down my grocery list a lot. I was constantly or just general to do lists. I would do, I would journal, you know, but with a paper and 10. So funny. Now, Jenna, you and I had a little system that we created. Do you remember this? You have to. It's one of my fondest memories of the show. We had specific boxes of other people's real life paperwork. Yes. Phil Shea bought like medical records. It was bizarre and these receipts.
越来越好了。实际上，我和克里德进行过很多次比赛，我把他的屁股打得落花流水。我至今还是有点纠结于他们让你带文件去片场这件事。他们真的这么跟你说了吗？不，你知道的，我不记得具体是怎么说的了，但我确实带了一些。我以前经常写购物清单。我经常写，或者写一些普通的待事清单。我会写日记，你知道的，用纸和笔。太搞笑了。话说珍娜，你和我当时建立了一个小系统。你还记得吗？你一定记得。这是我对这部剧最美好的回忆之一。我们有专门装别人真实生活文件的盒子。是的。
And I had this whole system where I was, I was stapling and I had a whole like certain things that would match and then I would bring them to you and then you would approve or disapprove sign. I remember this whole, oh my God, it was fantastic. It was amazing and it was very specific. My favorite thing about it, Kate, was that we would do this in the deep, deep, deep background when no one would appreciate it. It was really just for us and we would never break character and we would argue not with each other, but sort of like with the system. Yes. Yes, we were, yes. Like how they had these, yes, these alphanumeric characters that don't match any of the forms and are impossible to input into the computer. We had this whole like thing we were mad at
菲尔·谢买了一些医疗记录。这太离谱了，还有这些收据。我有一整套系统，我一直在装订文件，我有一套能把不同的东西匹配起来的流程，然后我会把它们拿给你，接着由你来批准或否决并签字。我记得这个，哦天哪，这太棒了。这太神奇了，而且非常具体。我最喜欢的一点是，凯特，我们总是在最深的背景板里做这件事，根本没人会注意到。这真的只是为了我们自己，我们从来不会出戏，而且我们争论的不是彼此，而是跟这个系统争论。是的。是的，我们当时，是的。比如那些跟任何表格都不匹配的字母数字代码，根本无法输入电脑。我们有一整套对
at corporate that we would do. We did. Oh my gosh. This was the greatest job in the world. This is the cutest thing that I, how is it that I was on set with you guys all these years? I didn't know. I, I didn't know you guys were doing this. Do you know what Oscar Nunez would do? With these health records, Oscar would find one that had something really peculiar and he'd circle it and highlight it and make it very important and he would hand it to me in the middle of a scene with great authority and it would say something like bulbous mass on eyelid, probably sty, recommended to drain of the pus and I'd be like, oh my God, I'm reading this in the background of a scene. We were so respectful though. Obviously, we never gave away anybody's
公司生气的戏码。我们确实这么干了。噢天哪。这是世界上最棒的工作。这太可爱了，怎么会这样？我跟你们在片场待了这么多年，居然不知道。我，我不知道你们俩在干这个。你知道奥斯卡·努涅斯会做什么吗？通过这些健康档案，奥斯卡会挑出一个非常奇特的病例，然后把它圈起来、做高亮标记，弄得好像极其重要一样，接着在拍摄一场戏的间隙，极其严肃地把它递给我，上面会写着类似“眼睑上长出球状肿块，可能是针眼，建议排脓”之类的内容。我会想：天啊，我居然在一场戏的背景里读这个。不过我们还是很尊重剧组的。很显然，我们从来没有在节目中泄露过任何人的
name or medical condition on the show. I want to say I have a memory that those forms were redacted like that the real personal info was blacked out. Did I do that to the forms or is that real? I think we did it to the forms. I literally think we did because I remember sometimes there were a little bit, but not everything, not every, not every, yeah. I, I do remember addresses being blacked out, but anyway guys, it was sort of creepy to know that you could buy old medical records in those days. I'm sure now they're all computerized and also the dates were from like three decades ago. It was like, there's a lot of stuff from, you know, 1960s. Yeah, the 80s was a big, yeah, yeah, it's so bizarre. I love, I love how we're trying to reassure people when the truth is,
名字或医疗状况。我想说，我记忆中那些表格是经过处理的，比如真实的个人信息都被涂黑了。是我对表格做了这个处理，还是本来就是真的？我觉得是我们自己处理的表格。我真的觉得是这样，因为我记得有时它们会被涂黑一点，但不是全部，不是每张都涂。我确实记得地址被涂黑了，不过话说回来，伙计们，那时候能买到旧医疗记录感觉怪怪的。我敢肯定现在它们全都是电子化的了，而且那些日期都是几十年前的。里面有很多来自，你知道的，20世纪60年代的东西。对，80年代是个大头，对，对，太诡异了。我喜欢，我喜欢我们试图让大家放心，但事实却是，
we clearly had things we shouldn't have had. Oh my God. But you know what, let's keep, let's keep trying to justify why it was okay. Well, it's fine. It's fine. What happened to dundermifulins data dundermifulins. We did not share any sensitive material, but I will say what I loved about that and the, and the real, the realness of the paperwork, it kept, it just kept everything. It was like a little focus for the lens. Yeah. One of my favorite things was they had stacks and stacks of some type of time code documentation from these offices and they were on really thin, like, like almost like the pages of a Bible thin, you know, and then they had all the little carbon slides in them. And I would sometimes smell the carbon slides because I like
我们手里确实有一些不该拿的东西。噢天哪。不过你知道吗，让我们继续，继续为这种做法是合理的进行辩解吧。好吧，没关系。没关系。邓德米夫林的的数据怎么了。邓德米夫林的数据。我们没有分享任何敏感材料，但我得说，我最喜欢的是那些文件的真实感，它让一切都保持了专注。它就像是镜头的一个焦点。对。我最喜欢的事情之一是，他们有一叠叠来自这些办公室的某种时间戳文档，纸非常薄，几乎就像《圣经》的纸那么薄，你知道的，里面还有所有的小复写纸。我有时会闻那些复写纸，因为我喜欢
the smell. It's like the smell of like a Sharpie. I like the smell. This is the eTrue Hollywood story right now. Angela's getting high. What is happening right now? Angela was sniffing the carbon in the background sometimes. This is how you got into character. I don't know. Well, you know, it's funny because Ken Coapas would do that thing, you know, like the general tone at the beginning when he would come. And this was all part of it, just like actually, you know, filming us working, just working and being like, you know, who are you working? It's funny. People have asked me like, how did you stay in character or whatever. I feel like those were our desks. So the crew really wasn't allowed to sit at our desks. So it was, it really did feel like an
那个味道。就像马克笔的味道。我喜欢那个味道。这简直就是真实好莱坞故事现场。安吉拉现在居然嗨了。这到底是怎么回事？安吉拉有时候会在背景里闻复写纸。这就是你进入角色状态的方式吗？不知道。好吧，你知道的，这很有趣，因为肯·夸帕斯会做那种事，你知道的，他刚来时定下的整体基调。这都是其中的一部分，就像实际上，你知道的，拍我们工作，就是工作，然后就像是，你知道，你在给谁工作？有趣的是，人们经常问我：你是怎么保持角色状态的，诸如此类。我觉得那是我们的办公桌。所以剧组其实是不允许坐在我们的办公桌后面的。所以从这个角度来看，它确实感觉像是一份
office job in that respect. Like you would literally walk in to set and just go right to your desk. It was kind of like focusing and specific and really wonderful. And it kept all of us in the game. And you know what? I wouldn't sit at anybody else's desk. No. Like I would never just go sit down in Phyllis' chair. No. Right? That was like her space. Sometimes Rain would sit at my desk to talk fantasy football with Brian. Right. And I would have to come kick him out of my seat. But I just, I just had such respect for the process. Like I just feel like the focus was always in the right place for our show. Yeah. Yeah. And I feel like I didn't always have a lot of lines, obviously, but I feel like there was something that I felt like I was kind of holding
办公室工作。就像你 literalmente（字面意思：字面意义上）走进片场直接走到你的办公桌前一样。这感觉既专注又具体，而且非常美妙。它让我们所有人都保持在状态中。而且你知道吗？我不会坐在别人的办公桌旁。绝不。就像我绝不会随便去坐在菲莉丝的椅子上。绝不。对吧？那是她的空间。有时雷恩会坐在我的办公桌旁和布莱恩聊梦幻足球。对。然后我不得不去把他从我的座位上赶走。但我只是，我对这个过程有着无比的敬意。我觉得我们节目的焦点总是放在正确的地方。对。对。而且我觉得我并不总是台词很多，很显然，但我觉得有一种感觉，我觉得我好像在为我们所处的现实坚守着一块阵地。这对我来说非常重要。我对此一直有着很强的意识。
the space for the reality that we were in. And that was very important to me. I was always very conscious of that. Well, we are super excited to talk to you about this amazing stunt that you did in this episode. I mean, holy cow, Kate, you get hit by a car. You get hit by a car. What was your first thought when you read this episode? Okay. I literally said, does she live? I literally said, does Meredith live? I said it right away. And then like I've been reading later that like there's been articles saying that one of the writers decided that, you know, they wanted a pitch that Meredith didn't live. And then they thought that was too dark. Greg thought it was too dark for Michael to have killed one of the employees. Oh my God. Yeah. How do you come back from that?
好吧，我们非常兴奋能跟你聊聊你在这一集里做的那个惊险特技动作。我的天啊，凯特，你被车撞了。你被车撞了。你读到这一集时的第一反应是什么？好吧。我当时脱口而出：她活下来了吗？我 literalmente（字面意思）说的是：梅瑞迪斯活下来了吗？我立刻就问了。然后就像我后来在文章里看到的，其中一个编剧提出过一个构想，就是让梅瑞迪斯没活下来。但他们觉得那样太黑暗了。格雷格觉得迈克尔撞死了一个员工，这情节太黑暗了。天哪。这怎么收场啊？
Yeah, I'm not sure. I'm not sure. But I was like, I, but I remember like I was so conscious of it because I was like, I know this isn't a soap opera. Like this could be it. But the first time we shot it, literally they played it almost like Meredith was a speed bump that he just like went over. Because like you were laying on the ground and he rolled over you. I was underneath the wheel. Literally. We finished shooting the episode. And then I think two weeks later, Dave Rogers, our Emmy winning editor, had an idea for an insert shot that he thought was so much more interesting than what we had shot, which was Meredith hitting the glass. And he asked our UPM Kent Zbornak to try it out and show it to me. He like Kent did it. Do you think he'd do it? I mean, he obviously did
对啊，我不确定。我不太确定。但我记得，我对此有清醒的认知，因为我想：我知道这不是肥皂剧。这完全有可能发生。但我们第一次拍的时候，实际上他们拍得简直就像梅瑞迪斯是个减速带，车直接从她身上碾过去了。因为你躺在地上，然后车从你身上碾过去了。我 literalmente（字面意思）在车轮底下。拍完这集之后。然后我想两周后，我们的艾美奖获奖剪辑师戴夫·罗杰斯想出了一个插入镜头的点子，他觉得这个点子比我们拍的要有趣得多，也就是梅瑞迪斯撞上挡风玻璃的镜头。他要求我们的联合制片经理肯·兹博纳克试一试，并拿给我看。肯真的照办了。你觉得我会答应吗？我的意思是，他显然
not know me because I would have said yes. And I totally want to say yes. I was going to say you would say yes. I would have. But season one, I remember Greg, there was a shot of Dwight and Michael dressed like Crockett and Tubbs from Miami Vice from the Halloween party. Do you remember that? Yes. Yes. And they had me dress up like Madonna. And I remember it was like, it was like maybe my second week there. And I was like, Oh, okay, I'll be Madonna, whatever. And like, they really went for it. I mean, I was, I was like 1987 Madonna. I was wearing like a boostier. It was nuts. I was just in the background. And I thought there was something about that. It was like my responsibility to do whatever as full out as possible. I don't know. I was like kind of up
不了解我，因为我肯定会答应。而且我绝对想说我愿意。我正要说你会答应的。我肯定会。但在第一季时，我记得格雷格，有一个镜头是德怀特和迈克尔打扮成《迈阿密风云》里的克罗克特和塔布斯去参加万圣节派对。你还记得吗？记得。是的。他们让我打扮成麦当娜。我记得那是，那大概是我入剧组的第二周吧。我就想：哦，好吧，我来演麦当娜，无所谓啦。而且他们真的很拼。我的意思是，我是，我打扮成1987年的麦当娜。我穿着紧身胸衣。太疯狂了。我当时只是个背景板。我觉得这里面某种程度上是我的责任，那就是尽可能百分之百地全情投入。我不知道。我当时什么都愿意尝试，因为我记得格雷格问：你介意这样做吗？我说：当然不。就像，当然可以。所以这拉开了梅瑞迪斯传奇的序幕，扮演全套麦当娜造型。但我其实觉得拍这种肢体喜剧太好玩了，因为我过得非常开心。我的意思是，我整个职业生涯做这种事都觉得很开心。但这个，绝对是达到了另一个全新的高度。所以 literalmente（字面意思），当我们去拍那个镜头时，我们得重拍一遍。而且史蒂夫当时没空，所以我们的制片助理丹·比尔斯，当时年纪轻轻的，穿着史蒂夫的夹克和衬衫。所以镜头里切到的是他的手。这是一个非常快的闪回。就像，你知道的，
for anything because I remember Greg saying, is it okay if you do this? And I was like, sure. Like, of course. So that that started the whole merit of the saga, being full Madonna. But I actually felt like it was so much fun to do the physical comedy because I have such a good time. I mean, I've always had a good time doing that my whole career. But like, this was so up another level for sure. So literally when we went to shoot it, we had to shoot it again. And Steve wasn't available. So Dan Beals, who was our PA, who was so young at the time, he had Steve's jacket on and shirt. So it was his hand that they would cut from. And it was it's such a quick swipe. Like it, you know,
你知道的，等等，是丹在开车？噢，好吧，他只是在车里，车是停着的。我从引擎盖中央开始。我得滚到挡风玻璃上，然后从车上滚到一个巨大的垫子上。所以你某种程度上必须用力把自己滚到那个挡风玻璃上。你得把身体重重地撞在挡风玻璃上，然后慢慢地从上面滚到停车场的一个垫子上。是的。我记得拍了第四条还是第五条之后，格雷格把我拉到一边，我们走到后面的巷子里，也就是仓库入口那个巷子里，我们在那里拍过鸟的葬礼，你知道那个巷子吧。对。对。对。他说：好了，跟我来，做几个开合跳。他居然陪我一起做开合跳，
you know, so wait, Dan was driving. Well, he was just in the car in the car stationery. I started in the center of the hood. I had to roll up to the glass and then roll off the car onto a giant mat. And so you sort of had to like with force roll into that windshield on your own. You sort of slammed your body into the windshield and then slowly rolled off of it onto a mat in the parking lot. Yes. And I remember after like the fourth take or fifth take, Greg took me aside and we went to the back where the warehouse entrance is in that alley where we shot like where the bird, you know, where they had the bird funeral, you know, the alley. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. He's like, okay, come with me and do some jumping jacks. He was like doing jumping jacks with me
就是为了让我彻底放松下来。我太喜欢格雷格了。我的意思是，顺便说一句，这太格雷格了。他是最棒的，就像最棒的导演。有趣的是，我最近看到戴夫·罗杰斯发给我一个未采用的废弃镜头。其实我在里面多转了一圈，我觉得那一圈其实更有趣一点。但我已经习惯看成片了。我想我当时只是被吓了一跳。等等，在某个平行宇宙里有这样一个镜头：你滚上去，然后在挡风玻璃上连续翻了两滚？没有，在挡风玻璃上是一次，但随后我从车上翻了两圈下来。哦，所以这简直太疯狂了。太疯狂了。好吧，伙计们，在第53秒，你可以看到凯特的脸贴在挡风玻璃上。我告诉你，拍完这个之后，我记得
just to get me really loose. I love Greg so much. I mean, that's so Greg, by the way. He's the great, like the greatest. It's funny. I just recently saw Dave Rogers sent me an outtake, another take that they didn't use. And I actually did an extra spin in there, which I actually thought was a little funnier. But I'm just so used to watching the one thing. I think it just caught me by surprise. So wait, there is a take of you out in the universe where you roll, you flip forward twice into the windshield? No, once in the windshield, but then I flip twice off the car. Oh, so it's like, it's insane. It's insane. Well, guys, at 53 seconds, you can see Kate's face up against the windshield. And I'm telling you, after we shot that, I remember
他们把这镜头用在了这集的宣传片里，因为这是第四季趣味长跑的第一集。我记得华金·菲尼克斯在最后一分钟取消了《今夜秀》的通告。所以他们基本上是因为宣传片太火了，就邀请我上《今夜秀》。那是我第一次上那个节目。太棒了。好吧，凯特，凯特，你简直就像个摇滚巨星。不过我得问你，如果你一次又一次地用力滚向挡风玻璃又滚下来，你会不会酸痛？你会不会？我们必须和之前拍摄的内容连上，因为他们不确定之前拍的能不能用得上。所以我必须服装连戏，我当时穿的是短袖和牛仔背带裤。是的，像个幼儿园老师。
they were using it in the promos for the episode because it was the first episode of season four fun run. I remember Joaquin Phoenix canceled at the last minute for the tonight show. So they asked me basically because of the promo was so much fun. Like they actually want to be on the tonight show. So that was the first time I did that. That was so awesome. Well, Kate, Kate, you're just like a rock star. I mean, I have to ask you though, if you're rolling with force into a windshield over and over and rolling off, were you sore? Did you like? We had to match what we shot before because they weren't sure about the before if they were going to see us before. So I had to match the clothes and I was wearing short sleeves and like a denim jumper. Yeah, kindergarten teacher.
我记得 Emmy 奖颁奖典礼就在接下来的一周，我身上到处都是瘀青。你得用身体粉底液吗？对，因为我觉得如果他们知道要那样拍特技，他们可能会给你穿上护具，并给你做相应的服装造型。噢天哪，这太疯狂了。好吧，凯特，你在剧里做过那么多特技。这是你最喜欢的吗？你甚至有最喜欢的吗？我觉得是。这是我最喜欢的。我也很喜欢那些奇奇怪怪的戏。德怀特进来的时候，我趴在男厕所的隔间上面。我在玩平板支撑。梅瑞迪斯在玩平板支撑。对。德怀特拿着灭火器冲进来，直接把我喷飞进了隔间里。我们用的是真正的男厕所录像村，也就是剧组嘉宾待的那两间浴室。对，对，对。他们把一个奇怪的
And I remember the Emmys were like the next week and I was so bruised. How do you use like body makeup? Yeah, because I think if they knew they were going to do the stunt that way, they probably would have padded you up and dressed you accordingly. Yeah. Oh my gosh, that's crazy. Well, Kate, you did so many stunts on the show. Was this your favorite? Do you even have a favorite? I think so. This was my favorite. I also loved being so weird. I was on top of the men's room stall when Dwight comes in. I was planking. Meredith is planking. Yes. Dwight comes in with a fire extinguisher and just blows her off into the stall. We use the real men's room video village where the guests were, those two bathrooms. Yeah, yeah, yeah. And they put like this weird
泡沫塑料床垫放在最上面，我当时心里祈祷：千万别往另一边倒，因为另一边什么都没有，我得保持平衡。这太疯狂了。不过，对，那真的是男厕所。我想：好吧，希望我落地不要太重，否则就要砸到马桶上了。这太离奇了，但真的很好玩。我想夸夸你的运动天赋。我知道安吉拉经常嘲笑我的运动天赋。来吧。来吧。不，没关系。我不会再提这个了，点到为止。不过，凯特，你的运动天赋惊人。我的意思是，做所有这些特技，我一点也不奇怪。我的意思是，我们知道你参加过《与星共舞》，表现惊艳，但你还连续多年演你的酒廊秀，
flim flam mattress on top and I was like, fingers crossed, I don't go the other way because there was nothing on the other side because I had to balance. It was so crazy. But yeah, and it was really the men's room. I'm like, okay, and this hopefully I don't land too hard because then I'm going to hit the toilet. It's so bizarre, but it's really fun. I want to give some props to your athleticism. I know that Angela has often shyded me for my athleticism. Here we go. Here we go. No, it's okay. I'm not going back to that any more than I just did. But Kate, you are amazingly athletic. I mean, in doing all these stunts, it doesn't surprise me. I mean, we know that you were on Dancing with the Stars and you were amazing, but you also did your lounge show,
“灯罩乐队”一演就是好多年。我记得去看过你的演出，你要不断地、重复地做深蹲。然后你把腿高高踢起，当时我就想：天啊，我觉得他们挑中你演梅瑞迪斯简直太幸运了，因为你完全胜任这些特技。太暖心了。我觉得对我来说，这也赋予了我力量。我没有拍头发着火的特技。我在《摩洛哥圣诞节》里拍了停车场里的所有特技，只是头发着火的那场没拍。还有打蝙蝠。你打了蝙蝠。那太疯狂了。而且你演得太真了。太疯狂了。然后我其实没有剃光头。我为此戴了光头套。所以我觉得这是两个。我想：好吧。我觉得你让你的头发保留着也挺好的。你知道我在说什么吗？我觉得格雷格
the lampshades for years and years and years. And I remember coming to see you in that and you do this deep squat repeatedly, repeatedly. And you kick your leg up and I was like, oh my gosh, I feel like they got so lucky with you as Meredith because you were qualified for these stunts. That's so sweet. I feel like for me too, it was empowering. I did not do the stunt with my hair on fire. I did do all the stuff in the parking lot of Moroccan Christmas. I just didn't do the hair on fire. And the bat. You did the bat. That was crazy. And you really sold it. So crazy. And then I didn't actually shave my head. I had a bald cap for that. So I feel like those are the two. I'm like, okay. I think it's okay that you let your hair be. You know what I'm saying? I think Greg
当时挺失望的。那是第一次我说：不，我可不干这个。好吧，我们能聊聊这集里大家都在医院看望你的那一幕吗？我的记忆中，要在那些场景里忍住不笑简直太难了。事实上，你能看到我们笑场了。我完全在这一集里笑场了。那次拍得可真欢乐。对。你对在医院拍戏有什么回忆？我记得有一场戏，德怀特说，如果他们拔掉你的呼吸机，你知道的，基本上那些能量就——就像是在浪费。就像他们花钱维持你的生命是在浪费钱。我超喜欢你当时说的那句：千万别拔呼吸机。什么呼吸机都别拔。噢天哪。太精彩了。我记得有一条是
was disappointed though. It was like the first time I was like, nope, not doing that. Well, can we talk a little bit about the moment in this episode where we're all in the hospital, we've all come to see you. I, my memory of this was it was so hard to get through those scenes without laughing. In fact, you see us break. Totally. I fully break in the episode. That was a really fun run. Yeah. What are your memories of shooting in the hospital? I remember there was one scene where Dwight talks about the fact that if they pulled the plug, you know, basically the energy like they were wasting. Like they're wasting money keeping you going. I loved it when you were like, do not pull the plug. Don't pull any plug. Oh my God. So good. And I remember the take when
史蒂夫为了道歉，他试图让我原谅他，而我就是不肯原谅。我就是不原谅。于是他索性决定爬到病床上来陪我。我觉得我当时反应慢了半拍，但我心里想：我直接尖叫出局了，因为我当时觉得。好吧，我们也吓了一跳，因为那是他即兴发挥的，你甚至能看到我们所有人都像是——当场石化了。然后我们说：迈克尔，住手。对。对。这真的让我们大吃一惊。完全如此。好吧，凯特，我们喜欢问嘉宾的另一个问题是：剧集杀青时，你们有没有顺走什么东西？你好大胆！我有梅瑞迪斯的包。我不知道我是不是一直把它当斜挎包背。对。对。你把它当手提包了。而且我把里面原本装着的所有东西都留下了。这就是为什么我至今还留着帕梅拉·摩根·比斯利和詹姆斯·邓肯·霍尔珀特的结婚证书。那是我们的婚礼吗？对。
Steve just, as an apology, he's trying to get an apology out of me and I won't apologize. I won't apologize. And so he just decides to climb into the bed with me. And I feel like I had a slight delayed reaction, but I'm like, I just started screaming because I'm like, like. Well, we were also surprised because he improvised that and you even see all of us, we sort of like freeze. And then we're like, Michael, stop. Yes. Yes. It really took us by surprise. Totally. Totally. Well, Kate, another question we like to ask our guests is if they took anything with them when the show wrapped. How dare you? I have Meredith's purse. I don't know if I always wore it like a cross saddle. Yeah. Yeah. You satcheled it. And I left everything in it that was still in
是婚礼流程单。所以这就是我当时做的。这是我们的婚礼流程单。婚礼派对人员。还有婚礼派对。对。这就是我在约翰·卡拉辛斯基的《美好新闻》节目里展示的那张，当时我们在做婚礼礼物环节。噢天哪。是不是很疯狂？太疯狂了，你居然把它塞在包里，而且还一直留着。我确实这么干了。我们经常这样，我们会用道具包。如果我们有道具，我们就会直接把它们塞进包里。完全是这样。对。我有——噢天哪，我这里面还有什么？我想我有。你是不是还留着一些旧台词纸？我总是把台词纸塞进包里。我确实有台词纸，但我也留着。我有《理发师陶德》的节目单，
there. So this is why I still had the marriage union of Pamela Morgan Beasley and James Duncan Halpert. Is that our wedding? Yes. It's the program. So this is what I did. It's our wedding program. The wedding party. And the wedding party. Yes. This is what I showed on some good news with John Krasinski when we did our wedding gifts. Oh my gosh. Is that crazy? That is so that you had just tucked it in your purse and you still had it. I did. We would do that, though. We would get prop purses. And like if we had props, we would just put them in our purse. Totally. Yeah. I have, oh my gosh, what else do I have in here? I think I have. Do you have some old sides? I would always put my sides in my purse. I do have sides, but I also have, I have Sweeney Todd
那是安迪在那个剧院演出时的。哇。还有塞西莉亚·玛丽·霍尔珀特的受洗教堂单，她受洗的时候。小西西受洗。噢天哪，凯特。这些太棒了。我懂。好吧，凯特，粉丝们超级喜欢梅瑞迪斯，你知道我们以后还会找你的。在我们结束之前，我们还有几集要补拍。在我们说再见之前，有什么可以和大家分享的吗？比如在哪里能找到你？你最近在忙什么？好的，我在 Instagram 上是 @TheRealKateFlannery，在 Twitter 上是 @KateFlannery。我每周去 K-10 的一家小拉面馆一次。但我其实在为“丰盛费城”做一些慈善工作，那是费城最大的食品银行。那是我的家乡。我正在和
from when Andy was performing in that theater. Wow. And I have Church of Angels Cecilia Marie Halpert when she got christened. CC's christened. Oh my gosh, Kate. These are amazing. I know. Well, Kate, fans love Meredith and you know we're going to be hitting you up. We've got a few more episodes to cover before we're done here. Before we say goodbye, is there anything we can share with everyone? Like where to find you? What you're up to? Yes. I, well, on Instagram at The Real Kate Flannery, on Twitter at Kate Flannery. I go to a little ramen place once a week in K-10. But I'm actually doing some charity work for Phil Abundance, which is the biggest food bank in Philadelphia. That's my hometown. I'm working
WMMR 合作，那是当地的大型广播电台。他们一直有普雷斯顿和史蒂夫主持的《早安秀》。我上他们的节目好几年了。离我爸爸家 literalmente（字面意思）只有五分钟路程。就像，我从床上滚起来，如果我在城里，我就会去，而且我偶尔会蹦出个四个字母的脏话。所以他们在导播台上有个按钮，专门叫“弗兰纳里按钮”，因为直播有四秒，你知道的，五秒的延迟规则。就像，那些 FCC（联邦通信委员会）法规，天哪，太疯狂了。不管怎样，我太爱这帮伙计了。他们正在产生巨大的影响。“丰盛费城”正在做一次巨大的物资筹集。他们总是在感恩节前夕这么做。但今年规模更大，因为疫情，也因为有那么多的家庭
with WMMR, which is the big radio station. They always have the Big Morning Show with Preston and Steve. And I've been doing their show for years. And it's literally like five minutes from my dad's house. Like, I will roll out of bed. And if I'm in town, I just, and I occasionally sometimes let a four letter word slip. So they literally have a button on their panel that says the Flannery button because there's a four second, you know, five second rule. Like, those FCC, gosh, it's crazy. But anyway, I love these guys so much. And they're making such a difference. Phil Abundance is, they're doing a huge push. They always do it right before Thanksgiving. But this year is even bigger because of the pandemic and because so many families are
急需帮助。有那么多的生意无法正常运转，我们不得不等待直到大家能再次聚在一起的那一天。我们一定能再次聚在此刻。但在那之前，你知道的，大家可以访问 philabundance.org。我会为他们做一些宣传推广工作，而且我会，你知道的。好的，这太棒了。我们应该提一下你是宾夕法尼亚人。对。而且你的家人、你爸爸在费城开过一家酒吧。酒吧叫什么名字？兰诺伊酒馆。他想名字想了一整晚才想出来。不，我开玩笑的。我爷爷也想过一个名字。好吧，凯特，我们很喜欢你这样回馈费城，我们绝对会，你知道的，在我们的社交媒体上发一下大家在哪里可以找到这些信息。
in need. And there's so many businesses that are not happening and that we have to wait until we can all be together again. And we will be together again. But in the meantime, you know, you guys can go to philabundance.org. And I'm going to be doing some, a little bit of press for them. And I'll be, you know. Okay, that is so great. And we should have mentioned that you are from Pennsylvania. Yes. And that your family, your dad had a bar in Philly. What was the name of the bar? Lannoy's Tavern. He was up all night trying to figure out a name. No, I'm just kidding. My grandfather came up with a name too. Well, Kate, we love that you are given back to Philly like that. And we'll definitely, you know, we'll put in our socials where people can find that.
那就太棒了。非常感谢你们，伙计们。我爱你们。很高兴见到你们。我也爱你们。非常感谢你，凯特。这太棒了。你得再来。我很乐意。哦，我们回来啦。安吉拉，和凯特聊得太开心了。她看起来太美了，惊艳动人。我们在播客里通过 Zoom 和很多人聊过天。大多数人出镜时都一团糟。凯特·弗兰纳里可不是。没有。她看起来棒极了。而且凯特，这太有趣了，我们对你感激不尽。我们还有很多内容要聊，最好抓紧时间开始吧。对。让我们来剖析这一集吧，女士们。首先，珍娜，我想跟你分享一下我们拍这一集的那周你都在干什么。准备好了吗？好的。有人去翻了
That would be awesome. Thank you so much, you guys. I love you. So good to see you. Love you too. Thank you so much, Kate. This was amazing. You have to come back. I would love to. Oh, we are back. Angela, that was so great talking with Kate. She looks beautiful, stunning. We have been talking to a lot of people through Zoom for our podcast. And most people show up like a hot mess. Not Kate Flannery. No. She looked amazing. And Kate, that was so fun. And we can't thank you enough. And we have a lot to cover. We better get into it. Yes. Let's break down this episode, lady. First of all, Jenna, I would like to share with you what you were doing this week that we filmed this. Are you ready? Okay. Someone went digging into
旧电子邮件。哦，我有点害怕。别害怕。虽然我也可以把这些黑历史公诸于世，但你也可以。噢天哪。好的。2007年7月31日，全体演员收到了一封来自肯·兹博纳克的电子邮件。上面写着：大家好，关于本周五，即8月3日，这是我们当天的日程安排。上午8点45分。参加 NBC 环球影城反骚扰研讨会。地点在3号摄影棚。上午9点。反骚扰研讨会，强制出席。上午10点。服装试穿，服装车。上午11点。剧本围读剧集，《趣味长跑》，编剧车。中午。演员体检。邮件就到这儿结束了吗？如有任何问题请致电，肯。哦，就这样？就这些？我以为是——首先，我觉得这是一个有趣的视角，
old emails. Oh, I'm kind of scared. Don't be scared. Although I could burn it to the ground, but so could you. Oh dear. Okay. On July 31st, 2007, the whole cast got an email from Kent Zabornak. That said, hey all, for this Friday, August 3rd, here's our schedule for the day. 845 a.m. Check in with the NBC Universal Studios harassment seminar. This will be located on stage three. 9 a.m. harassment seminar, mandatory attendance, 10 a.m. costume fittings, wardrobe trailer, 11 a.m. table read episode, fun run in the writer's trailer. Noon, cast, physicals. Is that the end of the email? Please call if you have any questions, Kent. Oh, that's it? That's it. I thought it was, first of all, I thought this was an interesting perspective
让你看到我们在筹备一集节目时的一天是怎么度过的。确实是。你的情绪被调动起来，就像：你想知道你当时在干什么吗？我想我只是没想到答案会是：你参加了一个反骚扰研讨会，还做了一个体检。我的意思是，我只是在想：我当时在干什么？我都等不及知道了。我的意思是，我不得不说，如果瓶子里的精灵给我一个愿望，我绝不会选择重过这一天。好吧，好吧。好吧，我只是觉得这是一个非常有趣的视角。A，它展示了我们为了开启新一季必须要做的事情。而且，B，我们在八月份拍摄了《趣味长跑》上下集。好吧，这部分的节目，我们是在室内拍摄的，但是各位，我们要去室外跑步。那是八月。我只是觉得，我只是觉得这是一个有趣的视角，珍娜。我喜欢。太棒了。我刚刚还以为你要透露什么更刺激的事呢。就这些，除了我的演员体检。我不知道。还有我的服装试穿。好吧，我很兴奋。显然，我看到肯发来的这封邮件时非常兴奋。好吧，很高兴你把它存着，因为这绝对是个宝贝。哦，闭嘴吧。你闭嘴。你应该把它做成剪贴簿。你闭嘴。德怀特会怎么说？闭上你的嘴。我可能把那封邮件删了，因为我喜欢保持收件箱整洁。我很高兴你把它留着，我觉得。我不知道该说什么了。我不知道该怎么顺话头切入这一集了。
that you saw what a day would be like as we prep an episode. It is. You're built up to like, would you like to know what you were doing? I guess I just wasn't expecting the answer to be. You attended a harassment seminar and got a physical. I mean, I just thought like, what was I doing? I can't wait to find out. I mean, I have to say, I wouldn't pick this day to redo if a genie in a bottle ever gave me a wish. Okay, okay. Well, I just thought this was a very interesting perspective. A, it shows what we had to do to start a new season. And also, B, we filmed fun run part one and part two in August. Okay, this part of the episode, we're inside, but folks, we're going to be running outside. It's August. I just think, I just think that's
让你看到我们在筹备一集节目时的一天是怎样的。确实是。你的心理建设是，你想知道自己在做什么吗？我猜我只是没想到答案会是。你参加了一个骚扰研讨会并做了一次体检。我的意思是，我只是在想，我当时在做什么？我迫不及待地想知道。我的意思是，我必须得说，如果神灯里的精灵给我一个愿望，我绝不会选择重过这一天。好吧，好吧。嗯，我只是觉得这是一个非常有趣的视角。第一，它展示了我们为开启新季度必须做的事情。还有第二，我们在八月拍摄了趣味赛跑的第一部分和第二部分。好吧，这一部分的节目，我们在室内，但各位，我们要去室外跑步。那是八月。我只是觉得，我只是觉得那是
interesting perspective, Jenna. I love it. It's great. I just thought you were going to let me in on something more exciting. That's all than my cast physical. I don't know. And my wardrobe fitting. Well, I was very excited. Clearly, I was very excited to find this email from Kent. Well, I'm glad you saved it because that's a keeper. Oh, shut up. You shut it. You should scrapbook that. You shut it. What would Dwight say? Zip your lid. I probably deleted that email because I like to keep it tidy in box. I love that you saved it, I think. I don't know what to say. I don't know how to segue into the episode.
有趣的视角，珍娜。我喜欢。太棒了。我只是以为你会让我了解一些更令人兴奋的事情。仅此而已，比我的演员体检还要兴奋。我不知道。还有我的试衣。好吧，我当时非常兴奋。显然，我看到肯特的这封邮件时非常兴奋。好吧，我很高兴你把它保存了下来，因为这值得留作纪念。哦，闭嘴。你也闭嘴。你应该把它做进剪贴簿里。你闭嘴。德怀特会怎么说？把你的盖子拉上。我大概把那封邮件删了，因为我喜欢保持收件箱整洁。我很高兴你把它保存下来，我觉得。我不知道该说什么。我不知道该如何过渡到这一集节目。
How about we get into this episode? All right, we start off with Michael eating some cereal. And at nine seconds, my background, folks, you can see that red pot basket thing that fell out of Jan's box as she was leaving corporate. No, you're kidding me. It's sitting right there. Oh my gosh, I love that so much. Yeah, she's put her things around the condo. Well, we had a big fan catch at this moment from Hannah A., Robert F., Christine J., Adrian Gibbs, Chelsea Warren, and many others who wrote in to say that Michael is eating cereal from Wegmans. And Wegmans is a local East Coast grocery store. They wanted to know whose idea was it to feature these Wegmans products. That would be Phil Shea. Yeah,
我们开始聊聊这一集吧？好的，我们从迈克尔吃麦片开始。大家看背景，在九秒左右，可以看到那个红色的锅篮，那是简离开总公司时从她的箱子里掉出来的。不，你在开玩笑吧。它就放在那儿。哦天哪，我太喜欢这个细节了。对，她把自己的东西摆满了公寓。嗯，我们在这一幕收到了很多粉丝的彩蛋反馈，来自汉娜·A、罗伯特·F、克里斯蒂安·J、阿德里安·吉布斯、切尔西·沃伦，还有许多其他人写信说，迈克尔吃的是韦格曼斯（Wegmans）的麦片。韦格曼斯是东海岸当地的一家杂货店。他们想知道是谁的主意要在剧中特写韦格曼斯的这些产品。那应该是菲尔·谢伊（Phil Shea）。对，
I was going to say how to be Phil Shea. He was so great about doing that kind of research. But how in the world did Phil Shea get Wegmans raisin brand and Wegmans soy milk? I have no idea. I'm impressed. Listen, Phil Shea is the guy that knows a guy. He's got a guy. Phil Shea's got a guy. He's got a guy on the ground in Scranton going to the Wegmans and Scranton, which by the way, I looked it up as open seven days a week from six a.m. to midnight and is located at 1315 Cold Spring Road. There you go, folks. If you want to eat the raisin brand that Michael is eating, that's where you can get it. Add it to your Dunder Mifflin Scranton tour. Exactly. Well, then Michael enters the bedroom to reveal that Jan is still sleeping. She's probably going
我正想说是菲尔·谢伊的主意。他在做这种道具考证方面一直很厉害。但是菲尔·谢伊到底是怎么弄到韦格曼斯葡萄干麦片和韦格曼斯豆奶的？我完全不知道。我很佩服。听着，菲尔·谢伊就是那种有门路的人。他有人脉。菲尔·谢伊有人脉。他在斯克兰顿有内线，能去斯克兰顿的韦格曼斯买东西，顺便说一句，我查了一下，那里一周七天营业，早上六点到午夜，地址是冷泉路1315号。各位，就是这样。如果你想吃迈克尔正在吃的葡萄干麦片，去那儿就能买到。把它加入你的邓德米夫林斯克兰顿观光之旅吧。没错。随后，迈克尔走进卧室，发现简还在睡觉。她可能要
to sleep for another few hours, he says. You can really see what she's doing to the condo in this. I mean, she has set up a vanity. There's a giant mirror. There's a clothes rack. I see too tall, enormous like candle things. There's a pink chair, but guess what? There's not. Well, Michael's little bed that he sleeps on during dinner party at the end of the bed. The bench at the foot of the bed that he says he sleeps on is not there yet. I noticed that as well. Well, maybe I'll email you about it someday. Maybe Kent sent us an email about it. You can delete it because you like a you like a tidy box. Oh my gosh. You're so mad at me about this email thing, but I like when you
再睡几个小时，他说。在这段里，你真的能看出她对公寓做了什么。我的意思是，她设置了一个梳妆台。有一个巨大的镜子。有一个衣架。我看到了两个高大无比的像蜡烛一样的东西。有一把粉红色的椅子，但你猜怎么着？没有。好吧，迈克尔在结尾的晚餐派对上睡的那张小床，床尾没有。床尾供他睡觉的长凳现在还不在。我也注意到了这一点。好吧，也许有一天我会为此给你发电子邮件。也许肯特给我们发了一封关于它的邮件。你可以删掉它，因为你喜欢——你喜欢一个井井有条的收件箱。哦天哪。你因为这封邮件的事情对我这么生气，但我喜欢你
listen back, when you listen back, Angela, I want you to hear like the anticipation that you built. I'm going to do it for you. I have an email that I found that is going to tell you what you were doing this week. I have it. I'm going to tell you. And then you were like, I could burn you to the ground with some of my emails. And I'm like, what is she going to say? And then you were like, 9, 8, 45 AM, check in for sexual harassment seminar. And I was like, wait, what? Hold up. That's where this is going. Hold up. You said, oh, should I be scared? And I said, no. I mean, I have the ones that can burn it down. So do you, but not this one. Clearly not this one. Clearly not this one. This week, you complied with your job and its requirements. Well, your new nickname
回听的时候，安吉拉，当你回听的时候，我希望你能听到你当时蓄势待发的那种期待感。我要为你重现一下。我找到了一封邮件，它将告诉你这周你都在干什么。我有。我要告诉你。然后你的反应是，我可以用我的一些邮件把你彻底摧毁。而我的反应是，她会说什么呢？然后你说：早上9点08分45秒，签到参加性骚扰研讨会。当时我的反应是，等等，什么？等等。事情原来是这样的。等等。你说：哦，我是不是该害怕？我说：不。我的意思是，我有那些能彻底摧毁一切的邮件。你也有，但不是这封。显然不是这封。显然不是这封。这周，你好好履行了你的工作职责。好吧，你的新绰号
is tidy box. So enjoy that. You know box is another word for vagina. I know. Hence the double entendre. Is that how you say that? Oh, good Lord, tidy box. Okay. We, what's happened to us? Well, we've been friends a long time. That's what's happened. All right. I love it. Well, Michael's in his car now. He's excited, you guys. He has a talking head. He thinks it's going to be a good year. Jan is home. Jim is back. Ryan is at corporate. Andy and Dwight are rocking the sales team. He feels blessed. He does. He also is not paying attention. And then bam, when he hits Meredith with his car. And we talked about this with Kate. What an amazing and exciting way to start the season, I have to say. I was surprised even when I rewatched it. I was like, oh God.
就叫“井井有条的收件箱”吧。好好享受吧。你知道收件箱（box）也是女性生殖器的另一个词吗？我知道。因此这是一个双关语。是这么说的吗？哦，天哪，井井有条的收件箱。好吧。我们，我们怎么变成这样了？嗯，我们做了很久的朋友了。事情就是这样。好吧，我喜欢这样。好了，迈克尔现在在车里。他很兴奋，伙计们。他有一个独白镜头。他觉得这将是美好的一年。简在家，吉姆回来了，瑞安在总公司，安迪和德怀特把销售团队搞得风生水起。他觉得自己被上帝保佑了。他是这么觉得的。同时他也没有专心开车。然后，砰的一声，他的车撞上了梅雷迪思。我们和凯特讨论过这件事。我必须说，以这种方式开始新的一季真是太惊艳、太刺激了。甚至当我重温这一段时我都感到很惊讶。我的天啊。
Well, remember in her interview when Kate said that her first thought was, oh my gosh, just Meredith live. And she heard that maybe there were some writers who had pitched that they kill Meredith. Do you know who they were? I got to the bottom of it. Oh no, this is probably a better email. I was emailing with Greg Daniels and Justin Spitzer. And they told me that, yes, they spent one evening pitching on this idea that maybe Meredith died, but it's more than that. It's not just that Meredith died. What? Greg told me that first of all, the idea was that they would shoot this as a spy shot. So they would not have a camera inside the car with Michael. It would just be a spy shot of him arriving at work for the day with the talking head as a voiceover. Okay. He said
好吧，还记得在采访中凯特说她当时的第一反应是：哦天哪，梅雷迪思还活着吗？并且她听说有些编剧曾提议直接写死梅雷迪思。你知道他们是谁吗？我查清了。哦不，这可能是一封更好的邮件。我和格雷格·丹尼尔斯（Greg Daniels）以及贾斯汀·斯皮策（Justin Spitzer）通过邮件交流过。他们告诉我，是的，他们曾花了一个晚上讨论一个想法，也许梅雷迪思死了，但不仅如此。不仅仅是梅雷迪思死了。什么？格雷格告诉我，首先，这个想法是以偷拍镜头的形式拍摄。所以车里不会有摄像头对着迈克尔。这只会是他开车上班的偷拍镜头，配上独白作为画外音。好吧。他说
that the pitch was that Michael would accidentally hit Meredith with his car and then thinking that no one could see him. He didn't want to leave any witnesses. And so in one pitch, he backed over her to make sure she was dead. Oh, good Lord. Justin told me that there was a pitch that Michael would go into his trunk and get one of those anti-theft devices called the club and then club her to death and then hide her body. Were they on drugs? Were they on drugs? I mean, seriously, that is the end of the show. There's no coming back. What were they thinking? That's what Greg said. Greg said, of course, we could never do this, but it was a pitch that was discussed for some time. And he said there were a few writers who were fighting for it. They were fighting for
他们的设想是，迈克尔不小心用车撞了梅雷迪思，然后以为没有人看到他。他不想留下任何目击证人。所以在其中一个版本中，他倒车从她身上碾过去，以确保她死透了。哦，天哪。贾斯汀告诉我，还有一个设想是，迈克尔会走到后备箱，拿出那个叫“方向盘锁”的防盗装置，然后把她活活打死，再藏起她的尸体。他们嗑药了吗？他们嗑药了吗？我的意思是，说真的，那直接就是大结局了。根本无法收场。他们在想什么？格雷格就是这么说的。格雷格说，当然，我们绝不可能真的拍这一段，但这确实是讨论了一段时间的一个设想。他说有几个编剧极力争取这个桥段。他们争取让
Michael to accidentally and then purposely do Meredith in. I need names. He wouldn't give me the names. I need names because I need to do a mental check on them. Holy cow. So yeah, that's what I that's what I found out. There was a moment where they were pitching that maybe Meredith doesn't make it. How? Craziness. Craziness. Also, I definitely don't want to know any of their late night pitches on Angela. Okay, thanks. Okay. All right, well, let's get into this episode. There's a lot to discuss. We start out with Jim and Pam talking to the IT guy, because Pam crashed the computers looking for some celebrity sex tape. Yeah, we got a lot of mail about this. I did a little bit of a mini deep dive. Well, let's see. Lydia Lind, Megan Harrison, Mary Newberry and Chris Roa
迈克尔先是不小心，然后又故意结果了梅雷迪思。我需要知道名字。他就是不肯告诉我名字。我需要名字，因为我得对他们进行一次心理评估。天哪。所以，是的，这就是我查到的情况。曾经有一段时间，他们在讨论也许梅雷迪思没能挺过去。多疯狂啊。太疯狂了。还有，我绝对不想知道他们对安吉拉有过什么深夜构思。好的，谢谢。好的。好吧，让我们进入这一集吧。有很多内容要讨论。我们一开始是吉姆和帕姆在跟IT人员说话，因为帕姆为了找某些名人的性爱录像把电脑弄崩溃了。是的，我们收到了很多关于这部分的信件。我做了一点小小的深入研究。好吧，让我们看看。莉迪亚·林德、梅根·哈里森、玛丽·纽伯里和克里斯·罗阿
all wrote in to say, it seems out of character for Pam to purchase a celebrity sex tape. Did your script say who's celebrity sex tape Pam clicked on or did you ever come up with your own idea of who it might be? Okay, Jenna, I think I know what the writers were hinting at here, because I googled, by the way, be careful googling this, I googled celebrity sex tape 2007. Yes. And the first thing that comes up is Kim Kardashian and her boyfriend were vacationing and made a video. And that got leaked. And it was released March of 2007. And there was a ton of like chatter, you know, just everyone was talking about it, right? And I think when the writers thought of this story idea, that's what they were thinking of. I don't have proof of that,
都写信说，帕姆去买名人的性爱录像，这似乎不太符合她的性格。你们的剧本里有没有写明帕姆点开的是哪个名人的性爱录像，或者你们有没有自己设想过那个人会是谁？好吧，珍娜，我想我知道编剧在这里暗示的是什么，因为我当时谷歌搜索了——顺便说一句，谷歌搜索这个时要小心——我搜索了“2007年名人性爱录像”。是的。弹出的第一条就是金·卡戴珊和她的男友在度假时拍了一段视频。然后它泄露了。那是2007年3月发布的。当时有大量的讨论，你知道，就是所有人都在谈论它，对吧？我想当编剧们想到这个故事创意时，他们想的就是这个。我没有证据证明这一点，
but this was written in around June of 2007. And that had happened in March. Yeah. So it was in the zeitgeist, but I don't think Pam would click on that. Like, is she here? Maybe she's just trying to be coy or I don't know, or something. It definitely shocked me when she said it. And also she's at work. She's at front reception. She's gonna watch this and shut down the whole computer grid. I don't know. It was a little bit of a stretch for me when I watched it too. I agree. Okay. Well, now Jim has a talking head. He talks about how he broke up with Karen. And it was really awkward because she came back and she said she wasn't going anywhere. And you can see Karen is letting him have it. They're in the kitchen. And as they're
但这大约是在2007年6月写的。而那件事发生在3月。所以这正是当时的时代风潮，但我认为帕姆不会去点那个。就像，她是那种人吗？也许她只是想装作害羞或者别的什么，或者诸如此类。当她说出那句话时，确实把我震惊到了。而且她在上班。她坐在前台。她居然要看这个，结果把整个电脑网络都搞瘫痪了。我不知道。当我看到这一段时，我觉得这稍微有点勉强。我同意。好吧，现在吉姆有一个独白镜头。他谈到了他是如何和凯伦分手的。这真的很尴尬，因为她回来了，并说她哪儿也不去。你能看到凯伦在狠狠地数落他。他们在厨房里。当他们
going at it, Phyllis and Angela shoot Pam a very judgy look. Yeah. Two minutes, 10 seconds. Judgy, Phyllis and Angela. Oh my gosh. Phyllis, Angela, combo sass. Combo sass. That's a lot of sass. And, um, but he said, you know, Karen said she wasn't going anywhere. But then the next day, her desk was cleared off and he's single and looking. Yeah. He wrapped that up quickly. You know, this was a highly anticipated episode because we had this big cliffhanger from the last season of Jim asking Pam on a date. And here now, Jim's saying he's single. Pam has a talking head where she says, Oh yeah, we went to dinner a few times. We, we talked through his breakup, but we're just good friends and it's, it's really nice to be friends again. Well, I'm with Kevin.
在激烈争吵时，菲尔丝和安吉拉向帕姆投去了非常评判的目光。是的。两分十秒。评判性的，菲尔丝和安吉拉。哦天哪。菲尔丝，安吉拉，双人刻薄组合。双人刻薄组合。这也太刻薄了。而且，嗯，他说，你知道，凯伦说她哪儿也不去。但第二天，她的桌子就被清理干净了，而他单身且在寻找新恋情。是的。他把这事处理得真快。你知道，这一集备受期待，因为我们在上一季结尾有一个巨大的悬念，就是吉姆约帕姆出去约会。而现在，吉姆说他是单身的。帕姆有一个独白镜头，她说：哦，对，我们一起吃了几次饭。我们，我们聊了聊他分手的事，但我们只是好朋友，能再次做朋友感觉真的很不错。好吧，我跟凯文一样。
I'm with Kevin. Are you kidding me? Yeah. Kevin's not having it. This was also a fun talking head for Kevin and Oscar because it starts with Kevin and then reveals Oscar when, when Kevin's like, right? And he's like, well, there's no evidence of intimacy and, you know, but they are both in very good moods. We had a couple of fan questions about this plot point. Okay. Julia Johnson and Madeleine Nelson noticed Pam has a big change to her hair and wardrobe. Is it because she's dating Jim now? And was there a lot of discussion about these changes? Oh yes. Well, her hair is very different. Yes. No more clipped back hair, crunchy hair. Yes. This change was a huge discussion. Pam is also not wearing her traditional button down shirt and her little cardigan.
我跟凯文一样。你在开玩笑吧？是的。凯文才不买账呢。这对凯文和奥斯卡来说也是一个有趣的独白镜头，因为它以凯文开头，然后当凯文说“对吧？”时，镜头揭示了奥斯卡的存在，奥斯卡说，嗯，没有亲密的证据，你知道的，但他们两个人的心情都非常好。我们收到了一些粉丝关于这个剧情点的提问。好的。朱莉娅·约翰逊和玛德琳·纳尔逊注意到帕姆的发型和服装有了很大的改变。这是因为她现在和吉姆约会在一块儿吗？关于这些改变，大家当时有很多讨论吗？哦，是的。嗯，她的发型很不一样。是的。不再是夹在后面的头发，那种硬邦邦的头发。是的。这个改变引起了巨大的讨论。帕姆也没有穿她传统的纽扣衬衫和她的小开衫。
She's wearing this cutesy little sweater with a little kind of bow that ties on the side. A very, very flirtatious shade of beige. I noticed that too. I was like, well, we didn't, we didn't go too far. Yeah. Get me the cutest beige sweater you can find. Well, it was a big discussion. We couldn't have this giant transformation. Greg did not want that moment from those movies where the sort of nerdy girl with the glasses falls in love. And then after she falls in love, she's got a gorgeous blowout and doesn't need her glasses anymore. You know, that whole story that we saw a million times growing up. It was called Kelly Kapoor. It was called Kelly Kapoor. You can only do that with one character. So we met our limit. But we did imagine that this
她穿着这件可爱的小毛衣，旁边系着一个小蝴蝶结。一种非常非常调情的米色。我也注意到了这一点。我当时想，好吧，我们还没——我们还没走得太远。是的。给我找一件你能找到的最可爱的米色毛衣。好吧，这引发了激烈的讨论。我们不能有这种巨大的形象转变。格雷格不希望出现那种电影里的桥段，就是那种戴着眼镜的书呆子女孩坠入爱河。然后在她坠入爱河之后，她有了一个华丽的吹风发型，而且再也不需要眼镜了。你知道，我们在成长过程中看过一百万遍的那种俗套故事。这叫凯利·卡普尔。这叫凯利·卡普尔。你只能在一个角色身上这么做。所以我们用额度了。但我们确实设想过，这段
new relationship would possibly affect Pam and how she looked and her desire to make an effort that maybe she didn't have a desire to make before. I get this. I mean, don't you remember Angela in your young love phases with someone new that you're dating? You give a little extra juge, right? Yeah, of course. We had a big fan catch regarding Pam's wardrobe. This came from Megan Robinson, Steph Baldwin, Laura Rolden, Haley McMurdy, and Kelly Ann Mim. They all noticed that Pam's necklace changes in this episode. You know what it is now? What? She's a butterfly. Fly butterfly. You're not that worm anymore. Fly. No. I think you mean caterpillar. Caterpillar. Squishy thing. You're not that squit. You're a beautiful flying in the wind. Yes, she has
新恋情可能会影响帕姆的外表，以及她想要打扮自己的愿望，这种愿望可能是她以前没有的。我懂这个。我的意思是，安吉拉，你不记得当你处于年轻热恋期时，和正在约会的新对象在一起的那种感觉吗？你会稍微多加一点打扮，对吧？对，当然。我们收到了一个关于帕姆服装的粉丝彩蛋。来自梅根·罗宾逊、斯蒂芬·鲍德温、劳拉·罗尔登、海莉·麦默迪和凯利·安·米姆。他们都注意到帕姆的项链在这个剧集里换了。你知道现在是什么吗？什么？是一只蝴蝶。飞吧，蝴蝶。你不再是那只虫子了。飞吧。不。我想你指的是毛毛虫。毛毛虫。软绵绵的东西。你不再是那个软乎乎的——你是一只在风中美丽飞翔的蝴蝶。是的，她已经
metamorphosized into a beautiful butterfly. That's right. No longer the unicorn, now the butterfly. Jim and Pam at three minutes are discussing their separate weekend plans in front of Kevin. It's making him crazy, right? Because he's not buying it. Yeah. Pam says, you know, maybe she'll go to the flea market at the drive-in. Guys, I'll look this up. There is a flea market at an old drive-in, and it was actually the Readers' Choice Award for Best Flea Market. It's located at the famous Circle Drive-In in the Circle Flea Fair. It's the largest flea market and farmer's market in northeastern Pennsylvania. That is 100% believable that Pam would be going. Yes. Jim says he's going to go mountain biking at Montage Mountain. Well, I look that up.
蜕变成为一只美丽的蝴蝶。没错。不再是独角兽，现在是蝴蝶了。吉姆和帕姆在三分多钟的时候在凯文面前讨论他们各自周末的计划。这把凯文快逼疯了，对吧？因为他根本不相信。是的。帕姆说，你知道，也许她会去汽车影院的跳蚤市场。伙ites，我查过了。在一个旧汽车影院确实有一个跳蚤市场，它实际上获得了“读者选择奖”的最佳跳蚤市场。它位于著名的环形汽车影院内的环形跳蚤集市。这是宾夕法尼亚州东北部最大跳蚤市场和农贸市场。帕姆会去那里是百分之百可信的。是的。吉姆说他要去蒙太奇山（Montage Mountain）骑山地自行车。好吧，我查了一下。
Correct me if I'm wrong, folks in Pennsylvania, but Montage Mountain has ski runs, but you can't mountain bike on it. Unless there's some trails I don't know about, I actually found an online petition from April of 2019 of folks wanting to mountain bike on Montage Mountain, but you can't and there's an online petition because people want to. Wow. Sorry. Sorry. Had to do a local deep dive. Well, you know what? Perhaps that's the evidence that Jim and Pam are not actually having separate plans that weekend. Because he would know. If Kevin knew that there was no mountain biking on Montage Mountain, he would know. Kevin doesn't know that because he's not athletic. He doesn't know. But Jim knows that. That's right. Jim got it wrong. Well, now Michael arrives
宾夕法尼亚的朋友们，如果我错了请纠正我，但蒙太奇山有滑雪道，你却不能在那里骑山地自行车。除非有什么我不知道的小径，我实际上在2019年4月找到了一份在线请愿书，是人们希望能在蒙太奇山骑山地自行车，但你不能，而且有一份在线请愿书，因为人们很想去。哇。抱歉。抱歉。不得不做一次地方深度考证。好吧，你知道吗？这也许正是吉姆和帕姆那个周末其实并没有各自计划的证据。因为他应该知道。如果凯文知道蒙太奇山没有山地自行车道，他就会知道。凯文不知道这一点，因为他不热爱运动。他不知道。但吉姆知道。没错。吉姆搞错了。好吧，现在迈克尔到了，
and he breaks the news that Meredith has been hit by a car. Yeah. Yeah. You know, luckily, he was there and he drove her to the hospital. He said the doctors did the best they could. They did everything they could to save her life and she's going to be okay. Yeah. And Stanley's like, why the hell would you say it like that? Who talks like that? It's so good. I love that line from Stanley so much. Leslie is so good in that delivery. He's so good. And I loved it when Andy's like, well, who hit her? And then Michael's like, kind of a good news, bad news there. I was able to be on the scene so quickly because I was in the car that hit her. And Jim's like, oh no. Yeah. Jim's like, who was driving the car? And that's what Pam is like. Oh, Michael. Oh,
他带来了一个消息，梅雷迪思被车撞了。是的。是的。幸运的是，他在现场，并且开车把她送去了医院。他说医生们已经尽力了。他们为了救她的命付出了全部努力，她会没事的。是的。斯坦利听了就说：你说话怎么这么阴阳怪气的？谁会这么说话？太棒了。我太喜欢斯坦利这句台词了。莱斯利这段台词的语气拿捏得太好了。他太棒了。我特别喜欢安迪说：那究竟是谁撞的？然后迈克尔说：这算是个好消息夹杂着坏消息吧。我能这么快出现在现场，是因为我就是撞她的那辆车（里的人）。吉姆就说：哦，不。是的。吉姆说：谁在开车？然后帕姆就说：哦，迈克尔。哦，
Michael. At four minutes, four seconds, there's a reaction shot of everyone and the accountants are all sort of standing together. Guys, the return of the floofy blouse. Oh, is it a floofy blouse in an accountant's stack? It's a floofy blouse in an accountant's clump. This is more of a clump than a stack. All right. But Jenna, you can also see that over the summer, I got bangs. Oh, yes. And Kim Ferry had to try to style my hair. But I think I have sort of stylish bangs. Oh, yeah. Well, there you go. I know. Well, now we are moving into Michael's office. Dwight is trying to make Michael feel better by explaining, it's going to be fine. I mean, it's only Meredith. But Michael is upset because he thinks everyone thinks he might be a murderer.
迈克尔。在四分四秒，有一个大家的反应镜头，会计组的人都站在一起。伙计们，蓬蓬衫回归了！哦，会计堆里出现了一件蓬蓬衫？这是一群会计堆里出现了一件蓬蓬衫。这与其说是堆，不如说是群。好吧。但是珍娜，你也能看到，在夏天的时候，我剪了刘海。哦，是的。金·费瑞不得不努力帮我打理发型。但我认为我的刘海还算挺时尚的。哦，是的。好吧，就是这样。我知道。好吧，现在我们要走进迈克尔的办公室了。德怀特正试图让迈克尔感觉好点，他解释说：一切都会好起来的。我的意思是，那只是梅雷迪思。但迈克尔很难过，因为他觉得大家都认为他可能是个杀人犯。
Or they were looking at him like he was a murderer. Can you imagine if some of the writers had had their way? No. No kidding. Gosh. Well, now Pam is going to go around the office. She thinks everyone should visit Meredith and she's collecting money so they can buy her flowers. Yes. But Angela says she can't go because Sprinkles is sick and Angela needs to go home at lunch to give Sprinkles some medicine and eat lunch with her cat. Yeah. And you guys, there are wonderful deleted talking heads from this episode. So many characters have great talking heads. But this is a talking head that would have happened right before Pam walked over to Angela. And I have to read it to you because it's so fun to me. Angela has a talking head that says, I've had Sprinkles
或者他们看他的眼神就像在看一个杀人犯。你能想象如果有些编剧真的按他们的想法拍了会怎样吗？不。开什么玩笑。天哪。好吧，现在帕姆要在办公室里转转了。她觉得每个人都应该去探望梅雷迪思，她在筹集资金好给她买花。是的。但安吉拉说她不能去，因为斯普林克尔斯（Sprinkles，猫名）生病了，安吉拉需要在午休时回家给斯普林克尔斯喂药，并陪她的猫吃午饭。是的。而且伙计们，这一集里有非常精彩的被删减独白镜头。好多角色都有很棒的独白。但这是一个本来应该发生在帕姆走向安吉拉之前的独白镜头。我必须读给你听，因为它对我来说太有趣了。安吉拉有一段独白说：我已经养了斯普林克尔斯16岁了。我从会计学校毕业时收养了它。我知道我想要什么样的人生。一种只有猫才能提供的陪伴和不可预测的美好时光的人生。猫咪带来的不可预测的美好时光。你知道，猫真的能带来不可预测的美好时光。克里德·布拉顿给我发过这句话。只有猫才能提供的不可预测的美好时光。克里德前几天还给我发过这个。我太喜欢了。所以，是的。所以安吉拉有那段你没能看到的独白，它真的让人觉得这不仅仅是一只猫对她而言。我的意思是，我们本来就知道这一点。但当帕姆暗示安吉拉应该去，并且说她在翘掉派对策划委员会的工作时。安吉拉被惹恼了。萨姆，我能来一段“帕姆式刻薄”吗？
for 16 years. I adopted her when I graduated from accounting school. I knew the kind of life I wanted. One with a companionship and unpredictable good times only a cat offers. The unpredictable good times a cat offers. You know, cats really do offer unpredictable good times. Creed Bratton has texted me this sentence. An unpredictable good time only a cat offers. Creed texted me that the other day. I love that. So, yes. So, Angela has that talking head and that you didn't get to see and it really sort of builds up like this is like more than a cat to her. I mean, we already know that. But when Pam suggests that Angela like should go and that she's like ditching on her party planning committee duties. Angela's ticked. Sam, can I get a PAMSAS?
“帕姆式刻薄”！是的。有人给我们写信了，佩吉·班克尔、劳伦·科尔温。他们直接用全大写字母写着：在五分35秒处，出现了一次重大的“帕姆式刻薄”。是的，我同意你们的看法。帕姆说：你的其他猫不能陪它吗？安吉拉则说：它们之间有宿怨、嫉妒、小团体。这个女人的家里到底在发生什么？我必须关于这个场景告诉你一件事。这就是我以为你要告诉我的事，当你对我说你曾就这一集给我发过一封电子邮件时。为什么？以及关于我这周在干什么。为什么？亲爱的，拍这场戏的时候我宿醉得非常非常严重。就像超级宿醉那种。如果你看这场戏里的我，跟其他每一场戏相比，你都能从我的脸上看出来。我整个人就像——我是灰色的。我有点发绿。为什么？
PAMSAS! Yeah. We had some people write in Page Banker, Lauren Corwin. They just wrote in all caps major PAMSAS at five minutes 35 seconds. Yeah, I agree you guys. Pam says, can't your other cats keep her company? And Angela's like, there's bad blood, jealousies, clicks. What's happening at this woman's house? I have to tell you something about this scene. This was what I thought you were going to tell me when you said that I had written you an email about this episode. Why? And about what I was doing this week. Why? Lady, I was really, really hungover when we shot this scene. Like super hungover. And if you look at me in this scene compared to every other scene, you can see it on my face. I am like, I am gray. I'm kind of green. Why?
我的眼睛肿得厉害。我永远不会忘记。所以拍这场戏的前天晚上，我和一个朋友去了一家墨西哥餐厅，她点了玛格丽塔酒。好吧。我以前真的从来没喝过玛格丽塔。哦，不会吧。真的，真的，千真万确。我们聊过这个。我没有什么喝酒的经验。我只是，你知道的，我喝过大都会鸡尾酒。为了演好喝醉的帕姆，我不得不做过喝酒的功课。所以我啜了一小口。是的。然后我觉得：这太美味了。我太喜欢这杯酒了。然后在这顿饭的过程中，我又喝了三杯，三杯，三杯。然后，你知道的，亲爱的，这场戏是第二天早上的第一场戏。我们的通告时间超级早，我真的深有体会。就像我——我根本没有足够的时间从我的三杯
My eyes are puffy. I will never forget it. So the night before this shoot, I went to a Mexican restaurant and I was with a friend who ordered a margarita. Okay. I had never really had a margarita before. Oh, no way. Yes, yes, it's true. We've talked about this. I did not have a lot of experience with drinking. I just, you know, I had a cosmopolitan. I had to research drinking in order to play drunk Pam. So I took a sip of it. Yeah. And I was like, this is delicious. I love this drink. And then I had three, three, three over the course of this dinner. I then, you know, lady, this scene was the first scene of the next day. We had a super early call time and I was really feeling it. Like I didn't, I had not had enough time to recover from my three
玛格丽塔酒中恢复过来。哦，是的。我的通告时间通常是早上5点、5点半左右。所以你当时浑身都在冒龙舌兰酒的汗。是的。所以我刚才以为你说你有一封关于我这周在干什么的邮件时，我在想：哦天哪，难道我给安吉拉写过关于那些玛格丽塔酒的事吗？抱歉让你失望了。你当时有一场强制性的集体剧本围读会和一个性骚扰研讨会。完全正确。不管怎样，这就是我的小八卦。每次我看到这场戏，我都会想起我第一次喝三杯玛格丽塔酒的那个夜晚。好吧，现在我永远都会记住了。所以现在迈克尔不得不给瑞安打电话，因为瑞安是他的老板，他得告诉瑞安他在公司物业上用公司的车撞了梅雷迪思。是的。瑞安在这段里简直是个狠人老板。他显然，
margaritas. Oh yeah. My call times were routinely like 5am, 5.30. So you were, you were sweating tequila. I was. And so I thought when you said earlier that you had an email from me about what I was doing this week, I was like, oh my gosh, did I write Angela about those margaritas? Sorry to disappoint. You had a mandatory physical table read and a sexual harassment seminar. Exactly. Anyway, that's my little, that's my little tidbit. Every time I see this scene, I'm reminded of the night that I first drank three margaritas. Well, now I'll always remember it. So now Michael has to call Ryan because Ryan is his boss and tell him he hit Meredith on company property and with his company car. Yeah. And Ryan is such a badass boss in this. He's clearly,
他的表现就像是在做老板，用这种方式跟迈克尔说话。好吧，然后我们看到了瑞安的独白镜头，瑞安有了新造型。哦，他留着那个——你管那叫什么？那不是胡子。那是一种永久的胡茬。是的。就像是下午五点钟的胡影，但这是一种选择。这是一种选择。对。是的。而且他的头发全都向后梳了。他有点像那种戈登·盖柯（Gordon Gekko）的风格。是的。他看起来应该去演电视剧《继承之战》。他看起来就是那样。是的。对。而且他有一种同样的油腻态度。他说：有些人一直叫我神童，你知道的，其实我不太确定那是什么意思。好吧，我想我确实知道那是什么意思。他——哦，太尴尬了。是的。太棒了。这是，
he's like, and being the boss and talking to Michael this way. Well, and then we go to the Ryan talking head and Ryan has a new look. Oh, he's got his like, his, what do you call that? It's not a beard. It's like a, the permanent stubble. Yeah. It's like a five o'clock shadow, but it's a choice. It's a choice. Yeah. Yeah. And his hair's all slicked back. He's got like kind of a Gordon gecko thing going on. Yeah. He looks like he should be in the show succession. That's what he looks like. Yes. Right. And he has the same kind of like cheesy attitude. He's like, some people keep calling me, you know, wonder kid, you know, not really sure what that means. Well, I guess I do know what it means. He's, oh, it's so cringy. Yeah. It's great. This is,
我们现在将一窥这种新动态会是什么样的。好吧，接下来是一场我非常喜欢的戏，安吉拉，因为这是一场德怀特和安吉拉的秘密戏份。还记得办公室里的人，我们不知道你们在约会，对吧？所以你们俩基本上还是那种秘密情侣，每当你们想和对方说话时。你们都得表现得诡异地神神秘秘的。对。我的意思是，大概只有吉姆知道，对吧？还有帕姆，吉姆和帕姆在这个时候希望已经谈过了吗？我们还是不知道。你本来会这么觉得的。所以亲爱的，我有一大段台词，里面讲到了斯普林克尔斯所有的药物，我做得就像你在《海滩游戏》里做的那样。我把它正着背倒着背烂熟于心，以便我可以毫不费力地把它说出来，
we're going to get a glimpse now of what this new dynamic is going to be like. Well, then we have a scene that I love Angela because it's a Dwight and Angela secret scene. Remember the people in the office, we don't know you're dating, right? So you guys are still kind of like a secret couple whenever you want to talk to each other. You have to go be like weirdly secretive about it. Yeah. I mean, I guess only Jim knows, right? And Pam and Pam have Jim and Pam hopefully talked about it at this point. We still don't know. You would think. So lady, I had a long speech where I talk about all of Sprinkles medications and I did that thing like you did on beach games. I learned it backwards and forward so that I could say it just effortlessly,
你知道的，但是，但就是这样。萨姆，你能播放那段剪辑吗？所以你需要我做什么？我都写下来了。有一个糖尿病注射针剂。在手中滚动胰岛素。不要摇晃它。她吃饭时要搭配血管紧张素转化酶抑制剂。你必须把她直接放在盘子前面，否则由于白内障她会看不见。将一粒欧米伽脂肪酸胶囊混入她的肾脏药物中。你需要在她吃完饭15分钟后喂她这个。还有，哦，有一种真菌药膏，因为她尾巴下面有感染。所以你必须抬起她的尾巴，把药膏直接涂在她尾巴的根部。我很高兴你把它背下来了，安吉拉，因为当我看到那个时，我在想。我以为答案是肯定的，因为你的语气
you know, but, but here it is. Sam, can you play that clip? So what do you need me to do? I wrote it out. There's a diabetes shot. Roll the insulin in your hands. Don't shake it. She gets an ACE inhibitor with her meal. You have to put her right in front of the dish or she won't see it because of the cataracts. Mix one capsule of omega fatty acid in with her kidney medicine. And you want to give that to her 15 minutes after she's eaten. And oh, there's a fungal cream because she has this infection under her tail. So you're going to have to lift her tail and put the cream right at the base of her tail. I love that you memorized it, Angela, because when I watched that, I wondered. I thought the answer was yes, because you delivered it
就像你很清楚一样。如果你有一只生病的猫，你就会知道，对吧？你不会去搜寻这些信息。你会直接知道的。哦，是的。道具部门给了我这本蓝色的记事本，上面写着所有的不同步骤，但并不是按顺序写的，也不完全是。所以其实，如果我看这本记事本，反而会把我搞糊涂。但我把这本写满了斯普林克尔斯所有药物的记事本保存了下来。这就是我在戏里递给德怀特的那个。他拿着它。我把它保存下来了。我从来没有撕掉第一页，我到现在还留着它。而且整本记事本都是没用过的。第一页上就写着斯普林克尔斯所有的药以及如何照顾它。哦天哪。哦，看。哦，等等。哦，我拍了张照片。
like you knew. And if you had a cat that was sick, you would know, right? You wouldn't be searching for that information. You would know it. Oh yeah. And they had the props department had given me this blue notepad with all of the different steps written out, but not in the same order, not exactly. So like, actually, if I looked at the notepad, it would have messed me up. But I saved the notepad with all of Sprinkles medications. And it's the one I hand Dwight in the scene. He's holding it. I saved it. I never tore off that first page and I still have it. And the whole notepad is unused. And that first page just has all of Sprinkles, like medicines and how to care for her. Oh my gosh. Oh, look. Oh, wait. Oh, I took a picture of it.
你想看吗？好的，给你。太惊人了。但那不是你的字迹。不，不，不。那不是我的字迹。道具部门的某个人写出来的。哇。我们得把它发到播客上。我们会把它发到播客上的。好的。斯普林克尔斯的用药单要上播客了。嗯，我们收到了来自特雷西·普雷斯科特的粉丝提问，她是这样说的：我是亚特兰大的一名专注于猫科的兽医，我想知道在斯普林克尔斯的医疗需求方面，是否咨询过真正的兽医医学博士，因为安吉拉给德怀特的药物和治疗清单非常逼真。哦，太棒了。好吧，格雷格告诉我，他让编剧助理内特·费德曼和乔纳森·休斯去研究了准确的
Do you want to see? Yeah. Okay, here. That is amazing. But that's not your handwriting. No, no, no. It's not my handwriting. Someone in the props department wrote that out. Wow. We have to post that on the pod. We'll post it on the pod. Okay. Sprinkles medication going on the pod. Um, well, we got a fan question from Tracy Prescott, who said this, I am a cat focused veterinarian in Atlanta. And I was wondering if an actual doctor of veterinary medicine was consulted about Sprinkles medical needs, because Angela's list of medications and treatments she gave to Dwight were very realistic. Oh, that's fantastic. Well, Greg told me that he had the writer's assistants, Nate Federman and Jonathan Hughes do research into the accurate
猫咪药物。这就是为什么那份药物清单如此逼真的原因。好吧，干得好，编剧助理们。没错。好吧，听着，在我们继续之前，也许我们应该休息一下，因为接下来，迈克尔要试图——我不知道，弥补这个错误。他会去尝试。事情不会顺利的。从来都不会。好的，我们马上回来。好的，我们回来了，安吉拉，迈克尔走进了茶水间，试图动员大家为梅雷迪思种一棵树以示纪念。但你知道我给这场戏起名叫什么吗？你总是给场景起名字，而我给这个场景起了个名字。什么？约翰在吃爆米花。哦天哪。你有没有注意到他在整场戏里都在吃爆米花？不是胡萝卜，不是小胡萝卜，
cat medicines. And that is why that list of medicines is so realistic. Well, good job, writer's assistants. That's right. Well, listen, before we go on, maybe we should take a break, because coming up, Michael is going to try to, I don't know, right this wrong. He's going to try. It's not going to go well. It never does. No. All right, we'll be back. All right, we are back and Angela, Michael has gone into the break room in an attempt to rally everyone to plant a tree in honor of Meredith. But do you know what I titled this scene? You are always titling scenes and I have titled the scene. What? John eats popcorn. Oh my gosh. Did you notice he is eating popcorn through this whole scene? Not carrots, not baby carrots,
而是爆米花。他吃爆米花的方式，太——太小心翼翼了。他是想尽量不发出太大咀嚼声吗？我想他是想尽量不给收音造成麻烦，但他显然饿了，因为他从头到尾都在吃。天哪，这就是我们拿到餐饮服务部门送的那台小爆米花机的那一年吗？一定是的。这一定是拥有爆米花的第一周。我们对爆米花有点疯狂，然后音响部门，我想，说了一句：好了，伙计们，我记得它后来就没了。是的，但我们当时很兴奋。好吧，他在整场戏里都在吃爆米花。也是在这场戏里，帕姆向迈克尔解释，你知道的，我们只是打算去探望梅雷迪思。我们分批去，这样就不会给她造成太大压力。但迈克尔
but popcorn. And the way he's eating it, it's so, it's so delicate. Was he trying not to crunch too loudly? I think he was trying not to be a problem for sound, but he was clearly hungry because he eats it through the whole scene. Oh my God, was this the year we got that little popcorn maker by Craft Services? It must have been. This must have been the first week with the popcorn maker. We went a little crazy for popcorn and then the sound department, I think, said, okay, guys, I remember it went away. Yeah, but we were excited about it. Well, he's eating popcorn in this whole scene. And it's also in the scene that Pam explains to Michael, you know, we're just going to go visit Meredith. We're going to go and shift so we don't overwhelm her. But Michael is
却说：不，我们要一起去。同时去，我开车。所以吉姆和帕姆就说：好吧，我们可以分别用各自的车带大家去。然后奥斯卡说：分别用各自的车？凯文说：我不信。我懂。好吧，然后迈克尔有了一个独白镜头，他说：你知道，我身上有缺点，怎么着，起诉我啊？然后他说：不，不，不，别起诉我。但是珍娜，珍娜，这个独白有一个备选版本，它在删减片段里。把我笑得不行。它也在花絮里。史蒂夫根本演不下去。他一直在笑。是什么？好吧，这就是——这就是那个。有一个镜头他显然坚持演完了，因为它在删减片段里。他说：我不是个坏人。我是一个用汽车撞了女人的好人。
like, no, we're all going together. At the same time, I'll drive. So Jim and Pam are like, well, we can each take people in our separate cars and Oscars like separate cars. And Kevin's like, I don't believe it. I know. Well, then Michael has a talking head and he says, you know, I have flaws, you know, what, so sue me. And he's like, no, no, no, don't sue me. But Jenna, Jenna, there was an alt to this talking head and it's in the deleted scenes. And it made me laugh so hard. And it's also in the bloopers. And Steve couldn't get through it. He kept laughing. What is it? Okay, this is, this is it. There's one take clearly he got through it because it's in the deleted scenes. He says, I am not a bad guy. I am a good guy who runs over women with his car.
为什么我这么难把我的意思表达清楚？哦天哪，太搞笑了。史蒂夫演出来的方式太棒了。太棒了。我得去看看那个。是的，你必须去看看。好吧，我们不知道他们究竟是怎么到达的。但整个小分队确实到达了医院。迈克尔带了一大束气球，整个小分队除了德怀特。没错，因为德怀特去照顾斯普林克尔斯了。大家聚集在梅雷迪思的病床周围。我们和凯特讨论过这一幕，关于史蒂夫是如何即兴发挥在那个瞬间爬到她身上的。他当时试图给她一个拥抱。这太神奇了。太棒了。这里有一个被删减的场景，克里德在大家离开时，直接顺走了她小塑料杯里的所有药。它们当时正放在她的托盘上。哦，克里德直接把她所有的药都塞进口袋里了。他当然会这么做。好吧，我有一个最喜欢的场景片段，我想问问你，因为我觉得这可能是你即兴发挥的。当迈克尔试图让梅雷迪思原谅他时，他说她应该想想《圣经》，因为上面说原谅仅次于神圣，而你嘟囔了一句：那是清洁。那是我的即兴发挥。哦，我还想提一下这一幕里的那个护士，她是一个来自即兴喜剧团（IO）的即兴演员。她的名字叫西尔维亚·麦克卢尔（Sylvia McClure）。好吧，我查了她的IMDB，发现了一件非常有趣的事。除了在《办公室》里扮演护士之外，她还在《不安分的青春》（Young and the Restless）、《嗜血法医》（Dexter）和《谍影迷情》（Intelligence）中扮演过医生，在
Why am I having such a hard time getting my message across? Oh my gosh, that is funny. And the way Steve does it is so good. That's good. I have to go watch that. Yeah, you have to. Well, we don't find out exactly how they get there. But the entire gang does arrive at the hospital. Michael has a whole bunch of balloons and the entire gang minus Dwight. That's right, because Dwight has gone to take care of sprinkles. Everyone gathers around Meredith's bed. And we talked about this scene with Kate about how Steve improvised crawling on top of her in that one moment. He's like trying to give her a hug. It's pretty amazing. It's pretty great. There is a deleted scene from this moment where Creed, as they're exiting, just grabs all her meds
《死亡之夜》（Night of the Dead）中扮演过护士，还在某个单元剧里扮演过接待护士。她演过很多护士和医生，顺便说一句，她还曾两次被选角扮演修女。这非常有趣。这就像是一种奇怪的刻板定型。是的，完全如此。好吧，我过去常常得到很多学校老师和护士的试镜机会。你演过护士或医生吗？是的，其实我在一部叫《促销员》（The Promotion）的电影里演过儿科护士。我在一集《神探阿蒙》（Monk）里演过医生，还在我们万圣节特辑之一里短暂演过性感护士。你在试镜时最常被定型为什么类型的角色？在《办公室》之前。在《办公室》之前。古怪。古怪的女孩。怎么说？比如古怪的、古怪有趣的邻居。古怪的邻居。是的。是的，我接到了很多学校老师、
out of the little plastic cups. They're sitting on her tray. Oh, and Creed just pockets all her meds. Of course he does. Well, I had a favorite moment from the scene and I wanted to ask you about it because I think maybe you improvised it. When Michael is trying to get Meredith to forgive him, he says that she should think about the Bible because it says that forgiveness is next to godliness and you mutter, that's cleanliness. I did improvise that. Oh, I also wanted to mention in this scene the nurse who is an improv person from IO. Her name is Sylvia McClure. Well, I looked at her IMDB and I found this very interesting. In addition to playing a nurse on the office, she has also played a doctor on Young and the Restless, Dexter and Intelligence, a nurse in
女服务员和护士的角色。好吧，我得告诉你，我们谈过我们在这一场里笑得有多厉害，但在11分22秒时，你可以看到我们笑场了。如果你仔细找的话，那就是迈克尔爬到梅雷迪思身上的那一刻。好吧，现在我们可以回到办公室了，我们会看到德怀特正在告诉安吉拉一些坏消息。而她正急切地想见他。她想知道进展如何。你一眼就能看出来。然后他说：嘿，小猴子。她问：有什么问题吗？嗯，你把电视开着，你的猫死了。我的角色就问：什么？然后他说：斯普林克尔斯。那只白色的死了。是的，他把名字记错了。这很糟糕。这真的很糟糕。这不会有好结果的。安吉拉，你立刻就变得非常情绪化，而且不是那种搞笑的方式。就像这是我们的剧集允许角色成为真人
Night of the Dead and a receptionist nurse on the unit. She's played a lot of nurses and doctors and incidentally she's also twice been cast as a nun. That is very interesting. It's like a weird typecasting. Yeah, exactly. Well, I used to get a lot of auditions for school teachers and nurses. Have you ever played a nurse or doctor? Yes, actually, I played a pediatric nurse in this movie called The Promotion. I played a doctor on an episode of Monk and I played a sexy nurse briefly in one of our Halloween episodes of The Office. What were you most often typecast as for auditions? Before The Office. Before The Office. Quirky. Quirky gal. What's up? Like Quirky, Quirky fun neighbor. Quirky neighbor. Yeah. Yeah, I was, I got a lot of just the school teachers,
的方式之一，因为安吉拉这个角色真的很爱她的猫。她心碎了。你从你的角色身上看到了这种真实的痛苦。你是如何为这场戏做准备的？好吧，格雷格告诉我，他说：你知道，安吉拉·马丁听到这个消息会痛不欲生。我需要你演绎出听到那种在当下几乎能摧毁你的消息时的情绪起伏。你知道的，我觉得我们所有人的人生中都有过这样的时刻，就是接到那种带着坏消息的电话，不幸的是。我只是想到了其中的几个时刻，你知道，一开始你只是完全处于震惊中，你甚至不确定自己听到了什么。是的。然后就像有人一巴掌扇在你脸上，带着这个信息。
waitresses and nurses. Well, I will tell you, we talked about how hard we laughed in this scene, but 11 minutes 22 seconds is when you can see us breaking. If you're looking for it, that's when Michael crawls on top of Meredith. Well, now we can go back to The Office and we are gonna find Dwight telling Angela some bad news. And she's anxious to see him. She wants to know how it went. You can just tell. And then he's like, hey, monkey. And she's like, any problems? Well, you left the TV on and your cat is dead. And my character's like, what? And he's like, sparkles. The white one is dead. Yeah, he gets the name wrong. It's bad. It is bad. This will not end well. Angela, you get so very immediately emotional and not in a funny way. Like this is one of the
然后你试图去理解它，但你无法理解。这是不可想象的。这根本说不通。你的身体正在经历这一切。你在震惊。你在难过。你的身体、你的大脑正试图让它变好，但你无法让它变好。你无法想通。你不明白为什么会发生这种事。我只是试图理清这一切。然后，是的，这就是我做的。那场戏你得拍很多条吗？你还记得吗？没有，我没有。我很庆幸这一点。在下一场戏中，你的角色还在哭。她和帕姆一起站在前台，你看上去像是已经哭了很久了。为了进入那种状态，为了在开始这场戏时就处在那样一个地方，你做了什么？你知道的，我很爱唠叨，所以我的直觉
ways that our show allowed characters to be real people because Angela, the character, really loved her cat. And she is heartbroken. And you see that real pain here from your character. How did you gear up for this scene? Well, Greg told me, he said, you know, Angela Martin hearing this news will be devastated. And I need you to play out the beats of hearing news that kind of destroys you in the moment. You know, and I feel like we've all had moments in our lives where we've gotten that phone call with some bad news, you know, unfortunately. And I just sort of thought about a few of those moments where, you know, at first you're just in total shock, where you're not really sure what you heard. Yeah. And then it's like someone slaps you in the face with the information.
会是，我和你一起站在前台，会想四处闲逛，你知道的，融入那个办公区。所以我做的其中一件事就是，在拍摄间隙，我独自一人走到电梯拐角处，我没有去跟别人闲逛。我只是试着让自己保持在那样的悲伤空间里。而且，嗯，还有，化妆部门，他们希望我的眼睛看起来真的很像是大哭过一场。他们真的做到了。所以我不得不把自己重新拉回那种情绪状态，再次变得悲伤。而且化妆部门的肯尼斯·帕尔（Kenneth Paul）给我化了妆，用了一种眼线，真的让眼内部，就是眼睛内部，看起来红红粉粉的。所以我的眼睛看起来很到位，然后我就在情绪上进入了那个状态。
And then you're trying to make sense of it, but you can't make sense of it. It's the unthinkable. And it doesn't make sense. And your body is doing all of that. You're in shock. You're sad. Your body, your mind is trying to make it right, but you can't make it right. You can't figure it out. You don't understand why it happened. And I was just trying to process through all of that. And, um, yeah, that's what I did. Did you have to do a lot of takes of that scene? Do you remember? No, I didn't. I was thankful for that. In the next scene, your character is still crying. She's standing at reception with Pam, and you look like you've been crying for a long time. What did you do to get there, to start the scene in a place like that? You know, I'm chatty, so my instinct
然后你试图去理解它，但你根本无法理解。这是不可思议的。而且这毫无道理。你的身体正在经历这一切。你处于休克状态。你很难过。你的身体、你的大脑试图让一切恢复正常，但你做不到。你无法弄明白。你不明白为什么会发生这种事。我当时只是在试图消化所有这些。然后，嗯，是的，我就是这么做的。那场戏你拍了很多条吗？你还记得吗？不，我没有。我很感激这一点。在接下来的戏里，你的角色还在哭。她和帕姆一起站在前台，你看上去就像已经哭了很久一样。为了进入状态，为了在开始那场戏时就处于那种境地，你做了什么？你知道的，我很健谈，所以我的直觉
would be, I'm standing by reception with you, would be to be hanging out, you know, being part of the bullpen. So one of the things I did was I went around the corner by the elevators, by myself, in between takes, and I did not hang out. And I just tried to stay in sort of that sad space. And, um, and also the, um, the makeup department, they wanted my eyes to really look like I had bawled my eyes out. And they did. So I had to get myself back in that emotional place and get sad again. And also the makeup department, Kenneth Paul, who did my makeup, did like this type of eyeliner that really made the inside, it was like on the, in the inside of your eye, reddish pink. So my eyes, my eyes looked the part and then emotionally I got there.
会是，我和你一起站在前台，会想四处闲逛，你知道的，融入那个开放式办公区。所以我做的事情之一就是在拍摄间隙，独自走到电梯旁的拐角处，没有去闲逛。我只是尽量让自己保持那种悲伤的氛围。而且，嗯，还有化妆部门，他们希望我的眼睛看起来真的像是大哭过一场。他们做到了。所以我必须让自己重新回到那种情绪状态中，再次感到悲伤。还有化妆部门的肯尼斯·保罗（Kenneth Paul），他给我化了妆，用了一种眼线笔，真的让眼内侧，也就是眼睛里面，呈现出红粉色。所以我的眼睛，我的眼睛看起来很像那么回事，然后在情绪上我也达到了那个状态。
Your eyes looked like you had three margaritas yesterday. Maybe, maybe that's what I, that should have been my prep instead of eyeliner and sad thoughts. Yeah. No, what happened was Laverne just showed Kenneth Paul a picture of me from the previous day and was like, make her look like that. No, but in all seriousness, Angela, when I was watching these series of scenes where your character is really, really devastated over the death of Sprinkles, I was just so beyond impressed with your performance and your range and your believability. It was just, this is just great, great work. Oh, thanks. I appreciate that. I really appreciated Greg writing the storyline for me. And I got to do all these things, you know, and, and,
你的眼睛昨天看起来像喝了三杯玛格丽特。也许，也许这就是我，那本该是我的准备工作，而不是眼线笔和悲伤的想法。是的。不，发生的事情是拉韦恩刚刚给肯尼斯·保尔看了我前一天的照片，然后说，让她看起来像那样。不，但说真的，安吉拉，当我看到这组场景时，你的角色因为小喷泉的死而真的、真的很崩溃，我简直对你的表演、你的戏路和你的可信度佩服得五体投地。这真的是，这真的是太棒、太棒的工作了。哦，谢谢。我很感激。我真的很感激格雷格为我写的这个故事情节。我得以做了所有这些事情，你知道的，而且，而且，
you know, his take as a director was always to try to keep it as honest as possible. Yeah. Well, there's another really great moment in this scene. And we actually had a fan write in, Katie Harwick said, I think we need to give a shout out to Michael when Angela's cat dies. Not only did he know her name, but he was overcome with grief. He cares so much for his employees. And it was just such a sweet moment to me. But I do have to ask, do you think he was truly sad? Or did he just see this as a distraction from hitting Meredith that everyone could talk about instead? I personally think he was very distraught about Sprinkles. Well, I agree. This happens at 12 minutes 41 seconds. And it is one of my favorite endearing moments of Michael.
你知道的，他作为导演的风格总是尽量保持尽可能真实。是的。嗯，这个场景里还有另一个非常棒的时刻。我们确实有一个粉丝来信，凯蒂·哈威克说，我觉得当安吉拉的猫死的时候，我们真的需要对迈克尔大加赞赏。他不仅知道它的名字，而且还悲痛欲绝。他太关心他的员工了。对我和来说，这真是太温馨的一个时刻了。但我不得不问，你觉得他是真的难过吗？还是他只是把这看作是一个可以转移大家注意力、不用再去谈论他撞了梅雷迪思的事的机会？我个人认为他为小喷泉感到非常难过。嗯，我同意。这发生在12分41秒。这是我对迈克尔最喜爱的、最动人的时刻之一。
Now, maybe because it's personal for me, because, you know, I played Angela Martin, I knew how much she loved her cats. But Michael, it's like that moment when the trick-or-treaters come to his house and you see his joy. It's like that moment when he shows up to Pam's art show. Michael really saw these people as his family. So Michael knew Angela's love of Sprinkles. Of course he did. And he was gutted to hear that Sprinkles died. The way he puts his hand up to his face and he kind of collapses into the wall. And he's like, oh, shoot, I'm sorry, Angela. I mean, could it get any worse? He's feeling all of that. He really feels bad. And now he gets Sprinkles' name right the first time. And then he makes a big speech and calls her Prinkle. So, you know, he does.
现在，也许因为这对我来说很私人，因为，你知道的，我扮演了安吉拉·马丁，我知道她有多爱她的猫。但是迈克尔，就像万圣节讨糖的人来到他家时你看到他的喜悦那样。就像他出现在潘的艺术展时的那个时刻。迈克尔真的把这些人当作他的家人。所以迈克尔知道安吉拉对小喷泉的爱。他当然知道。听到小喷泉死了，他心如刀割。他把手举到脸上，整个人有点瘫倒在墙上。他说，哦，天哪，对不起，安吉拉。我的意思是，还能更糟吗？他感受到了这一切。他是真的觉得很遗憾。现在他第一次就把小喷泉的名字叫对了。然后他发表了一大段演讲，却把它叫成了普林克尔。所以，你看，他确实如此。
That's right. He says so many bad things have happened today. The computer crashes from porn, merit of this accident, and now Prinkles. We're cursed. This seals the deal. To him, that's it. The office is cursed. And now he's got to figure out how to break this curse. Yes, but he does say I'm not superstitious, but I am a little stitious. It's like he thinks they're two separate words. Well, we had a fan question about that line from Jessica Williard and Lauren Corwin. They said, that line makes me laugh every time who wrote this joke. I was curious too. Did you find out? I did. It was Gene Stupnitsky. Gene, hilarious. Yeah, I asked Greg and he said, I'm pretty sure it was Gene or Lee. I reached out to those guys. Gene said, yes, it was me. He remembers. They were
没错。他说今天发生了这么多不好的事情。电脑因为色情内容崩溃了，梅雷迪思出了事故，现在又是普林克尔。我们被诅咒了。这算是板上钉钉了。对他来说，就是这样。办公室被诅咒了。现在他必须想办法打破这个诅咒。是的，但他确实说过，我不迷信，但我有点迷信。就好像他认为这是两个不同的词。嗯，我们有一个关于那句台词的粉丝提问，来自杰茜卡·威利德和劳伦·科温。她们说，那句台词每次都逗得我大笑，是谁写的这个笑话。我也很好奇。你查到了吗？我查到了。是吉恩·斯图普尼茨基。吉恩，太搞笑了。是的，我问了格雷格，他说，我挺确信是吉恩或者李。我联系了他们。吉恩说，是的，就是我。他记得。他们当时
in a group and this talking head leads to a commercial break and they needed a button. They needed a little button at the end of this talking head so that they could go to commercial. And he said they were just trying to come up with something and all of a sudden he said, he shouted out, I've got it. This might be stupid, but how about this? And he pitched that line and it is so genius. It is such a good line and I hear that line quoted all the time. It is a Michael Scott classic line. It is. It's true. Well, speaking of classic Michael Scott, we're now going to move into one of Michael's conference room meetings. This is an epic conference room meeting. We were in this conference room all fricking day. We got loopy. We got punchy. I'm going to tell
在一群人里，而这段独白引出了一个商业广告插播，他们需要一个包袱。他们需要在这段独白结束时有一个小包袱，好让他们进入广告。他说他们当时只是在努力想出点什么，突然之间他说，他大喊道，我有办法了。这可能有点蠢，但这个怎么样？他抛出了那句台词，简直是天才之举。这是一句太棒的台词，我经常听到有人引用这句台词。这是一句迈克尔·斯科特的经典台词。确实如此。没错。嗯，说到经典的迈克尔·斯科特，我们现在要进入迈克尔的会议室会议之一了。这是一场史诗级的会议室会议。我们整整一整天都在这个会议室里。我们变得有点神志不清。我们变得有点疯疯癫癫。我要告诉
you where we flat out lost it. It's so good. Yeah. I also remember that they very specifically did not seat Jim and Pam next to one another. This was part of Jim and Pam's supposed like way of deflecting that we're dating. Yeah. And I remember that you have to just be sad and kind of cry through this scene and that I didn't want to chat you up too much because I knew you had to stay in that space. And I did. I did. I really stayed sad until the end when Steve made me break into laughter. So Michael in the scene is questioning his employees. He feels like someone must have done something to get this curse, right? Like have they violated an ancient Indian burial ground? And then, you know, he wants to know what everyone's religious beliefs are, which Toby says, Michael,
你我们在哪里彻底笑场了。太棒了。是的。我还记得他们非常刻意地没有把吉姆和潘安排坐在一起。这是吉姆和潘所谓的为了掩饰我们在约会的一部分手段。是的。而且我记得你必须在整个场景中保持悲伤并一直哭泣，而我不想跟你闲聊太多，因为我知道你必须保持那种状态。我确实这样做了。我真的保持着悲伤，直到最后史蒂夫让我忍不住笑出声来。所以在场景中，迈克尔正在盘问他的员工。他觉得一定有人做了什么事才招致了这个诅咒，对吧？比如他们是不是亵渎了古老的印第安墓地？然后，你知道的，他想知道每个人的宗教信仰是什么，托比说，迈克尔，
we can't you can't do that. You can't discuss that. Michael calls Toby Satan repeatedly in the scene one because he won a week of free pizzas. So he's like, I don't think there's a curse. And Michael's like, okay, Satan. So he goes around the room. Pam and Daryl are both Presbyterians. They high five. Phyllis has this great line where she says, I'm a Lutheran and Bob is a Unitarian who keeps things spicy. Creed said he's been a follower and a cult and a leader and a cult. The followers have more fun, but the leaders make more money. But Michael has decided he thinks maybe we should do an animal sacrifice. Yes, you know, that's going to do it. Maybe that would help. Yeah. And then he starts naming animals, but they don't exist. I wrote them down.
我们不能，你不能那样做。你不能讨论这个。迈克尔在场景中多次称托比为撒旦，一是因为他赢了一周的免费披萨。所以他说，我不认为有什么诅咒。迈克尔就说，好吧，撒旦。于是他在房间里转了一圈。潘和达里尔都是长老会信徒，他们击掌庆贺。菲利斯有一句很棒的台词，她说，我是路德派的，鲍勃是一神论者，他让生活充满情趣。克里德说他当过邪教信徒，也当过邪教头目。信徒更有乐趣，但头目赚更多钱。但是迈克尔已经决定，他觉得也许我们应该进行一次动物献祭。是的，你知道，那样管用。也许那会有所帮助。是的。然后他开始说出动物的名字，但它们根本不存在。我都记下来了。
He suggests that we sacrifice an animal that has the body of a walrus and the head of a sea lion, or the body of an egret with the head of a meerkat, or maybe one that has the head of a monkey with the antlers of a reindeer and the body of a porcupine. Okay, Jenna, when Steve started this runner, they just let him go. Do you remember this? Yes. He just started improvising different animal combinations. We didn't know what was going to come out of the guy's mouth. We all started dropping like flies, cracking up. And the other thing is, he would say it was such seriousness. And this was the comedy killer, the long pauses. He takes such a long pause before he says, body of a porcupine. Yes, we were on the floor. We were on the floor. I am not in any
他建议我们献祭一种有着海象的身体和海狮的头的动物，或者有着白鹭的身体和猫鼬的头的动物，或者也许是一种有着猴子的头、驯鹿的鹿角和豪猪的身体的动物。好吧，珍娜，当史蒂夫开始这个桥段时，他们就由着他发挥了。你还记得吗？记得。他开始即兴发挥各种动物组合。我们根本不知道这家伙嘴里会蹦出什么来。我们所有人都开始像苍蝇一样接连倒下，笑得前俯后仰。另一件事是，他说得无比严肃。而这就是喜剧杀手，长时间的停顿。他在说出豪猪的身体之前，停顿了那么长的时间。是的，我们笑得瘫倒在地。我们笑得瘫倒在地。我不在任何
background shots while he's doing these animal combinations, because I couldn't keep it together. And at 18 minutes, 11 seconds, you can see Craig Robinson covering his face. I saw it. I remember that. We were losing it. It was so funny. And they let him go for a long time. I mean, you are not seeing all of it. He went for so long. And I remember we were cracking up and we were just like, as a group, we're like, no, get it together. These are too good. We can't ruin these. Well, while all this is happening at the office, Dwight has gone to visit Meredith. And he has this talking head where he's saying, as he's sitting next to her, that sometimes the best thing to do is to put an animal out of its misery. He's a farmer. Yeah. You could power
背景镜头里，当他在做这些动物组合时，因为我根本憋不住。在18分11秒时，你可以看到克雷格·罗宾逊捂住了脸。我看到了。我记得这个。我们快笑疯了。太搞笑了。而且他们由着他说了很长很长时间。我的意思是，你并没有看到全部。他说得太久了。我记得我们笑得前俯后仰，我们当时就像，作为集体，我们就像，不，振作起来。这些太棒了。我们不能毁了它们。好吧，就在办公室里发生这一切的同时，德怀特去探望了梅雷迪思。他有一段独白，当他坐在她旁边时，说有时候最好的做法是给痛苦中的动物一个痛快。他是个农夫。对。你用梅雷迪思身上连接的
a small fan for two days with the amount of electricity Meredith is hooked up to. I have to say, please, if you go back to rewatch this episode during this speech by Dwight next to Meredith's bedside, please look at the woman in the bed on the other side. Okay. Over Dwight's shoulder. That's all I'm going to say. Just enjoy that performance the next time you watch this scene. It's wonderful. Oh my God, Jenna. When we were all crammed around Kate's bed, that woman was there. I swear that woman, it was like she was a real patient. She let out some kind of noise. And I thought we were all going to shit our pants. She was a background actor. But it was she was so real. She literally while we were standing there one time went like, I think they told her to maybe
电量可以为一个小型风扇供电两天。我必须说，求求你们，如果你回去重看这一集，在德怀特在梅雷迪思病床边发表这段演讲时，请看看另一边病床上的那个女人。好吧。在德怀特的肩膀上方。我只想说这些。下次你看这个场景时，好好欣赏一下那个表演吧。太精彩了。哦，天哪，珍娜。当我们全都挤在凯特的病床周围时，那个女人就在那儿。我发誓那个女人，就像她是个真正的病人一样。她发出了一种声音。我以为我们所有人都要吓得屁滚尿流了。她是个群演。但她太真实了。她简直在我们站在那儿的时候突然来了一句，我想他们可能告诉过她
make a moaning sound. Yeah. And her interpretation of that, we wouldn't loopy. Well, watch her in the background of the scene because she's excellent. So now the doctor comes in and Dwight has some questions for him. And you and I both know that this is our writer, Justin Spitzer. Yes, creator of some of your favorite Dwightisms, Justin Spitzer and the creator of the show, Superstore. Well, I reached out to Justin and he told me that he got this role after reading the part in the table read that he made Greg laugh, which Paul Eberstein has shared that this would happen. They wouldn't have some of the roles cast and they would have writers read them. And if a writer read a part, get ready because Greg, there was a good chance Greg was going to put you in the show.
发出呻吟声。是的。而她对这一指令的理解，我们当时都神志不清了。好吧，在场景的背景中注意她，因为她太棒了。现在医生进来了，德怀特有一些问题要问他。你我都知这其实是我们的编剧贾斯汀·斯皮尔策。是的，一些你最喜欢的“德怀特语录”的创作者，贾斯汀·斯皮尔策，也是《超级店员》的创作者。好吧，我联系了贾斯汀，他告诉我他在围读剧本时读了那个角色后得到了这个角色，他让格雷格笑了，保罗·埃伯斯坦曾分享过这种情况会发生。他们有时没有为某些角色选好演员，就会让编剧来读。如果一个编剧读了一个角色，那就准备好吧，因为格雷格很有可能会把你塞进节目里。
Well, he also told me that the look he gives to camera was actually him misunderstanding a piece of direction from Greg, that Greg did not intend him to like perform that line to the camera as like a little joke. Like, oh, so that's where it went. He's talking about Meredith's uterus. Yeah. But Greg left it in. I liked it. I liked it too. But he said that was not the intention. That was a mistake. Well, we learn in this scene that Meredith has been bitten by a bat, which we knew, but not only by a bat, but recently by a raccoon and a rat. What the hell Meredith? What is she doing? Honestly, a few of those animals could just live in her van. Meredith's van. Well, when Dwight comes back from the hospital, he fills Michael in on all of this.
好吧，他还告诉我，他给镜头的那个眼神实际上是他误解了格雷格的一个导演指令，格雷格本意并不是让他像开个小玩笑那样对着镜头表演那句台词。哦，所以它是这么来的。他是在谈论梅雷迪思的子宫。是的。但格雷格保留了那个镜头。我挺喜欢的。我也挺喜欢。但他说那不是原本的意图。那是个失误。好吧，我们在这一幕中得知梅雷迪思被蝙蝠咬了，我们本来就知道，但不仅被蝙蝠咬了，最近还被浣熊和老鼠咬了。搞什么鬼，梅雷迪思？她到底在干什么？老实说，其中好几只动物本来就可以住在她的面包车里。梅雷迪思的面包车。好吧，当德怀特从医院回来时，他把这一切都告诉了迈克尔。
Yes. He says, you know, it turns out Meredith had been exposed to rabies. Michael's like ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding. And that going to the hospital might have saved her life because she got a rabies vaccine. That is all Michael needed to hear. He hit her with a car and saved her life. Yes. Now he also says in this scene, Dwight says, the only way to treat rabies is to start treatment before the symptoms start. Well, I looked it up. This is true. Did you know, Angela, that nearly 100% of people who develop symptoms die from rabies? Die. It cannot be cured once you get it. I did not know that. Yes. So this is why you have to seek treatment immediately if you are ever bitten by an animal. And a lot of animals can carry rabies. But since I looked it up,
是的。他说，你知道的，原来梅雷迪思曾接触过狂犬病。迈克尔就像叮、叮、叮、叮、叮、叮。去医院可能救了她的命，因为她打了狂犬病疫苗。这就是迈克尔需要听到的全部。他用汽车撞了她然后救了她的命。是的。现在他在这个场景中还说，德怀特说，治疗狂犬病的唯一方法是在症状出现之前开始治疗。好吧，我查了一下。这是真的。你知道吗，安吉拉，几乎100%出现症状的人都会死于狂犬病？死亡。一旦染上就无法治愈。我以前不知道。是的。所以这就是为什么如果你被任何动物咬伤，必须立即寻求治疗。很多动物都会携带狂犬病。但既然我查过了，
I'll let you know that in the United States, the most likely way to transmit rabies is through bats, coyotes, foxes, raccoons, and skunks. In Africa and Southeast Asia, it is stray dogs. I mean, what about monkeys? There's parts of Indonesia. If you go up to Ubud, there's monkeys all over the place. Any animal bite. If you get bitten by any animal, just go. Go get a rabies vaccine. It also said- What about squirrels? Yes. Any animal. If any animal bites you, I'm just telling you the animals that are most likely to carry rabies in these locations. But any animal can give it to you. Is a mongoose on the list? Is a mongoose any animal? I'm just messing with you, but it's been really fun. Well, listen, here is the thing that I found most interesting. This is from the Mayo Clinic
我来告诉你，在美国，传播狂犬病最可能的方式是通过蝙蝠、郊狼、狐狸、浣熊和臭鼬。在非洲和东南亚，则是流浪狗。我是说，猴子呢？印尼有些地方。如果你去乌布，到处都是猴子。任何动物咬伤。如果你被任何动物咬了，直接去。去打狂犬病疫苗。它还说——松鼠呢？是的。任何动物。如果有任何动物咬了你，我只是在告诉你这些地方最有可能携带狂犬病的动物。但任何动物都能传染给你。獴在名单上吗？獴算任何动物吗？我跟你开玩笑呢，但这真的很有趣。好吧，听着，我发现最有趣的是这个。这是来自梅奥诊所
website. Here's what it says. Okay. If you wake up in the morning, okay, and there's a bat in your room. Okay. You should assume you've been bitten because a bat can bite you without waking you up. It also said if you find a bat by a person who can't tell you that they've been bitten like a child or an impaired adult, assume they have also been bitten and go get a rabies vaccine. Because once you show symptoms, there is no cure. Well, I was watching an episode of Our Planet, and they were talking about these baby seals, and they're vampire bats that go and try to just suck their blood, and they can hop. They hop around. The seals are the bats. The bats. They jump. I'm going to send you a video. They hop, and they are blood suckers. They hop and bite.
网站的。上面是这么说的。好吧。如果你早上醒来，好吧，你的房间里有一只蝙蝠。好吧。你应该假设自己被咬了，因为蝙蝠可以在不惊醒你的情况下咬你。它还说，如果你发现蝙蝠在一个无法告诉你是否被咬过的人身边，比如儿童或认知受损的成年人，也要假设他们被咬了，然后去打狂犬病疫苗。因为一旦你出现症状，就无可救药了。好吧，我当时在看一集《我们的星球》，他们谈到了这些小海豹，还有吸血蝙蝠，它们会去试着吸它们的血，而且它们会跳。它们会蹦来蹦去。海豹是蝙蝠。是蝙蝠。它们会跳。我要发给你一段视频。它们会跳，而且是吸血鬼。它们又蹦又咬。
They hop and bite. Yeah. Well, there you go, guys. There you go. That's your rabies cheat sheet. That's everything you ever wanted to know about rabies. Basically, if you get bit by an animal, that's what I learned. Get that rabies shot. Good. Oh, yes. That was the takeaway I was hoping for. Well, there you go. Well, Michael is thrilled to find out that he has saved Meredith's life. Oh, yeah. He walks into the bullpen. He declares that the curse has been broken. Turns out there is a God. Everything is great. But who is Jesus' dad? Yeah, he's not sure, I guess. And meanwhile, Kevin has been on the case this whole episode trying to figure out if Jim and Pam are dating. He's positive that they are,
又蹦又咬。好吧，就是这样，伙计们。就是这样。这就是你们的狂犬病速成手册。这就是所有你们一直想知道关于狂犬病的事情。基本上，如果你被动物咬了，这就是我学到的。去打那一针狂犬疫苗。很好。哦，是的，这就是我希望得到的收获。好吧，就这样。好吧，迈克尔得知自己救了梅雷迪思的命，兴奋极了。哦，是的。他走进办公区。他宣称诅咒已经被破除了。原来真的有上帝。一切都太棒了。但耶稣的爸爸是谁？好吧，他大概也不确定。与此同时，这一整集里凯文一直在调查，试图弄清楚吉姆和潘是不是在约会。他确信他们在一起了，
but it's the end of the day. And he's like, you know what? I guess they're not together. And now they probably never will be. And it's too bad because they're like PB and J, Pam Beasley and Jim. Yeah. And that was an inside joke because at this point, fans of the show had started calling Jim and Pam jam. Yes. They had mashed our names as jam. And so it was this funny thing that Kevin would call us PB and J and not jam. A little nod to the fans. A little nod. Well, you know what? We see Pam leave for the day. She gets in her car. She drives away. She's by herself. Clearly, the documentary crew is as suspicious as Kevin because they follow her as she drives off. It made me wonder, my gosh, how long do they follow us
但一天快结束了。他就像，你知道吗？我想他们没有在一起。而且他们现在可能永远也不会在一起了。太可惜了，因为他们就像PB和J，潘·比斯利和吉姆。是的。那是一个内部笑话，因为在这个时候，节目的粉丝们已经开始叫吉姆和潘“果酱（jam）”了。是的。他们把我们的名字混成了果酱。所以凯文叫我们PB和J而不是果酱，这是一件很有趣的事。对粉丝的一个小致意。一个小致意。好吧，你知道吗？我们看到潘下班离开。她上车了。她开车走了。她独自一人。显然，纪录片摄制组和凯文一样充满疑虑，因为在她开车离开时他们一直在跟着她。这让我纳闷，天哪，我们下班后他们到底跟了我们多久？
after we leave work? Well, I don't think you should be that worried because Pam doesn't drive very far. I was like, Pam, do better. You drove like four car lengths and then you pulled over. And then what? Are you going to just leave your car there? Does your car is not that far from work and you're just going to leave it? No, I'm not going to leave it. I'm going to pick up Jim. I think they could have done better. Well, you know what? This is the street we could get a permit for. And we couldn't block off the whole street. This is as far as I was allowed to drive. Well, it's true. I pull over and then Greg wanted to kind of further the misdirect. So he directed me to put my head down on the steering wheel, like maybe Pam pulled off the side of the road
好吧，我觉得你不用那么担心，因为潘根本没开多远。我当时想，潘，能不能表现好一点。你才开了大概四个车身的距离然后就靠边停车了。然后呢？你打算就把车留在那儿吗？你的车离单位没多远，你就要把它留在那儿？不，我不会留在那儿。我要去接吉姆。我觉得他们本可以表现得更好。好吧，你知道吗？这是我们能申请到许可的街道。我们不能把整条街都封锁。这就是我被允许开到的最远距离。好吧，确实如此。我靠边停车，然后格雷格希望进一步制造烟幕弹。所以他指挥我把头埋在方向盘上，就像潘把车停在路边，
because she was just having kind of an emotional moment. And maybe you'd find out what that was or why that was that she was sad or something like that. But of course, what happens is Jim comes over, he gets in the car, they share a kiss and then they drive away. Well, I loved this little moment that we got to see. I will say this, the way you slumped on the steering wheel, I did not think you were overcome with emotion. I thought you were awkwardly trying to hide. I'm going to say when I watched that back, it's one of my worst acting moments on the show. I thought you were trying to hide. The idea was that I was sort of like, oh, what a day. I needed to pull over because, oh, what a day this has been. I need a moment
是因为她当时正经历某种情绪化的时刻。也许你会发现那是什么，或者为什么她会感到难过诸如此类的。但当然，发生的事情是吉姆走过来，上了车，他们分享了一个吻然后开车走了。好吧，我喜欢我们看到的这个小片段。我得说，你趴在方向盘上的那个样子，我可不觉得你是被情绪淹没了。我觉得你是在尴尬地试图躲藏。我得说当我回看那个镜头时，这是我在剧里最烂的演技时刻之一。我以为你是在试图躲藏。我的想法是那种，哦，这算什么日子啊。我需要靠边停车，因为，哦，这真的是糟糕的一天。我需要一会儿
to collect myself. I mean, it didn't work. I don't think it worked. You thought I was trying to hide. I thought it worked because I thought Pam was trying to possibly cover her face from anyone of her coworkers who might be leaving since she didn't pull very far away from the building. Well, that's what I thought. It was strange. It was strange. But there you go. And on the DVDs, guys, there is a very interesting extra feature. There is a rabies PSA. It is Steve, looking like Steve, cute jeans, buttoned down. He has normal Steve hair, but he's sort of delivering it more like Michael, but he's Steve. I don't know. It's like it was written for Michael, but it's delivered by Steve. It's a rabies PSA. Remember those things on NBC? The more you know,
来调整一下自己。我是说，这没起作用。我觉得没起作用。你以为我在试图躲藏。我觉得起作用了，因为我以为潘可能是在试图向任何可能离开的同事遮住自己的脸，毕竟她离大楼并没有停得很远。好吧，我是这么想的。这很奇怪。这很奇怪。但就是这样。在DVD上，伙计们，有一个非常有趣的幕后花絮。有一个狂犬病公益广告。那是史蒂夫，看起来就像史蒂夫，穿着好看的牛仔裤，扣着衬衫纽扣。他有着正常的史蒂夫发型，但他有点像迈克尔那样发表讲话，但他就是史蒂夫。我不知道。就好像那是为迈克尔写的，但由史蒂夫来发表。这是一个狂犬病公益广告。还记得NBC上的那些东西吗？知道得越多，
bing, bing, bing, bing, or whatever. Yes. And he's giving a few tips about rabies, and then he says, rabies kills nearly 4,000 Americans every 1,000 years. Well, here's an interesting fact that I found, Angela. What? Which is that the day after this episode aired? This episode aired on September 27th, 2007. The next day was the first annual World Rabies Day. It was a global health day to raise awareness of rabies. So do you think NBC had Steve do a PSA? I don't know. I don't know. But what a weird crazy thing. Yes. And guys, if you get bit, get that rabie shot. I hope I made that clear in today's episode. I got it. I hope you also learned maybe don't drink three margaritas before you have a real
冰、冰、冰、冰，诸如此类。是的。他给出了关于狂犬病的几个小贴士，然后他说，狂犬病每1000年杀死近4000名美国人。好吧，我发现了一个有趣的事实，安吉拉。什么？就是这一集播出的第二天？这一集于2007年9月27日播出。第二天是第一届世界狂犬病日。这是一个旨在提高人们对狂犬病认识的全球健康日。所以你觉得NBC是让史蒂夫拍了一个公益广告吗？我不知道。我不知道。但这是一件多么奇怪而疯狂的事啊。是的。伙计们，如果你被咬了，去打那针狂犬疫苗。我希望我在今天的节目中把这一点说清楚了。我记住了。我希望你们也学到了也许不要在有一个极早的
early call time. Aspiring actors, maybe you can learn that from me today as well. Jenna, you're giving all kinds of gyms today. So many gyms. Well, thank you. You're welcome. Here's the takeaway from me today. Save the boring emails and then no one will hack you. That's right. Oh, there we go. Guys, that was fun run part one. We'll be back next week with fun run part two, where we actually run. Oh, man, do we? All right, guys, have a great week. Bye. Bye. Are you still here? Bye. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Irwin, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our producer is Cody Fisher. Our sound engineer is Sam
通告时间之前喝三杯玛格丽特。有抱负的演员们，也许你们今天也可以从我这里学到这一点。珍娜，你今天真是金句频出。金句不断。好吧，谢谢。不客气。我今天的心得是：保存好无聊的电子邮件，这样就没人能黑你了。没错。哦，好了，伙计们，那是欢乐跑（上）。我们下周将带着欢乐跑（下）回归，在那集中我们真的要跑步了。哦，天哪，我们真的要跑吗？好了，伙计们，祝你们一周愉快。拜拜。拜拜。你还在这儿吗？拜拜。感谢收听“办公室女士”。“办公室女士”由欧文、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利制作。我们的制作人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的音响工程师是萨姆
Kieffer and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubakow. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one month trial of StitcherPremium, use code office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
·基弗，我们的副制作人是艾恩斯利·布巴科夫。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。要收听无广告版本的“办公室女士”，请访问StitcherPremium.com。要免费试用StitcherPremium一个月，请使用优惠码office。这一集还没有评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。